Caption: things with the english language
Caption: if you draw it with a picture a diagram
Caption: or something like that it's it's right
Caption: in front of you
Caption: and i worked as an architect and i still
Caption: do sort of architecture stuff for a long
Caption: time
Caption: go in a room you put the picture up
Caption: everyone's got it in front of them and
Caption: you're talking to it and changing it
Caption: okay as opposed to trying to read
Caption: through and understand it you bring it
Caption: in much much faster
Caption: okay
Caption: so i'm going to talk a little bit about
Caption: my journey all right
Caption: and i'll do it with
Caption: with pictures
Caption: so
Caption: i don't know when you're in school and
Caption: you're asked to draw a landscape this is
Caption: kind of what you drew you know the
Caption: horizon some mountains the sun
Caption: gave it some color
Caption: okay so i'm going to start there
Caption: all right and this is my journey
Caption: so about 10 years ago
Caption: um i was using physical whiteboards
Caption: and
Caption: these are the sort of things i was you
Caption: know putting up on the screen
Caption: um
Caption: pretty bland but i guess i got the um
Caption: the the message across as to what we're
Caption: trying to do
Caption: okay
Caption: um and about 2012
Caption: i i wanted to start taking digital notes
Caption: and and using a tablet so i bought a
Caption: stylus optimized tablet
Caption: 2012 the apple pencil still didn't exist
Caption: you were told to use a finger
Caption: and
Caption: so i bought an android tablet and
Caption: i it never really worked well
Caption: um but
Caption: i i just persisted i went through about
Caption: four different android tablets with
Caption: styluses
Caption: um but my
Caption: my drawing on a tablet
Caption: looked worse than it did on a whiteboard
Caption: okay but i was using it
Caption: then
Caption: this happened
Caption: okay and everyone stopped going into an
Caption: office and i no longer had access to a
Caption: whiteboard
Caption: um but we had zoom
Caption: and all of a sudden a tablet with a pen
Caption: became really really handy
Caption: i could
Caption: you know join the zoom meeting with my
Caption: tablet
Caption: and i could draw kind of like on a
Caption: whiteboard but i was still pretty crap
Caption: at drawing okay still really crap at
Caption: drawing but at least i was able to do
Caption: something
Caption: and then early last year i changed jobs
Caption: and i started working for with confluent
Caption: and as a as an organization for their
Caption: solutions engineers of which i'm a
Caption: solutions engineer
Caption: um they had enabled um their workforce
Caption: with an ipad with an app called concepts
Caption: that i hadn't used before
Caption: and some other tools and i'll go through
Caption: the tools
Caption: and
Caption: it was a little bit eye opening i
Caption: thought wow this is really cool this
Caption: this actually works so if i show you
Caption: um
Caption: i guess what my white boards
Caption: look like within about a month of
Caption: starting working with those tools
Caption: at uh at confluence so
Caption: definitely improved right i'm starting
Caption: to to to draw things out now one of the
Caption: nice things about concepts and i i'm
Caption: going to say if you've got a an ipad
Caption: even if you've got android concepts
Caption: works on the android but the documents
Caption: aren't compatible between them and
Caption: there's it's sort of a couple of
Caption: versions behind on android
Caption: it's still okay all right but um
Caption: the infinite canvas so i can scroll left
Caption: right out in it it's just good to be
Caption: able to you know
Caption: zoom into detail like i'm doing here
Caption: okay and then about two months after i
Caption: joined
Caption: we had
Caption: someone new come into leadership and she
Caption: suggested because we were all using this
Caption: that we should maybe do some training in
Caption: it and
Caption: i attended a two-day workshop
Caption: on
Caption: visual facilitation
Caption: by a company in australia called the
Caption: humble pm now picablo is a german
Caption: company
Caption: they um
Caption: they basically sell material around
Caption: visual facilitation
Caption: and um there's a guy called mark
Caption: huntleby
Caption: that runs these courses so um they're
Caption: quite expensive it's about fifteen
Caption: hundred dollars if you can get your
Caption: company to to sponsor you know this it'd
Caption: be really cool
Caption: and um
Caption: i'm gonna show you these drawings here
Caption: that i started this this morning
Caption: um that's using the picablo sort of
Caption: technique
Caption: all right and this this kind of really
Caption: um took off for me right so
Caption: my
Caption: my drawing just changed and it it
Caption: it changed on a sort of a rapid
Caption: progression
Caption: so i will go into the tools
Caption: so with digital
Caption: i have an ipad
Caption: and drawing with a pencil on an ipad if
Caption: you've got one it's it's not very good
Caption: it sort of slips and slides everywhere
Caption: um samsung with their
Caption: stylus is much much better i much prefer
Caption: to note take on a samsung style on a
Caption: samsung tablet
Caption: and and i use that in meetings so i
Caption: typically carry a macbook my ipad and a
Caption: samsung tablet so
Caption: lots of things to keep charged
Caption: it gets better if you put a screen
Caption: protector
Caption: on the glass and you can get this one
Caption: off of amazon it's called uh it's from
Caption: belmond
Caption: it's about 25 for two
Caption: screen protectors
Caption: and it gives it a bit of a matte finish
Caption: so it feels more like writing on paper
Caption: they've tried to emulate their paper
Caption: with the pencil
Caption: so i would recommend it
Caption: and of course the concepts app this is a
Caption: really good app
Caption: and if you have problems their support's
Caption: really good there's only a small team
Caption: out of
Caption: california that write this
Caption: and then lastly
Caption: you don't
Caption: need this and i could show you how this
Caption: works except my macbook's at the back of
Caption: the room so i can't uh it basically is a
Caption: airplay receiver running on your macbook
Caption: so that i can present
Caption: from my ipad up here or wherever it is
Caption: onto a screen somewhere with a hdmi
Caption: cable
Caption: okay so that's digital
Caption: now
Caption: with paper
Caption: um
Caption: if you do the buckler course and you
Caption: don't have to do it but if you do it you
Caption: get one of these sort of packs
Caption: and you get these refillable pens
Caption: from newland and they have like hundreds
Caption: of colors they have them for paper they
Caption: have them for white boards
Caption: um very large tips for doing shading and
Caption: things so they're really good if you
Caption: sort of you know
Caption: if your work is in a room and you are
Caption: you know doing sort of agile
Caption: facilitation and you want to draw out a
Caption: journey or something like that and
Caption: you're doing it on paper these are
Caption: really good much better than what you
Caption: can get from an office works
Caption: okay
Caption: they're expensive and you can buy them
Caption: online
Caption: also
Caption: with actually i'll show that later i'll
Caption: leave that for now
Caption: okay
Caption: and again i've also i've already
Caption: mentioned this but uh
Caption: with whiteboards again the newland
Caption: markers
Caption: and i'm going to suggest that if you're
Caption: buying markers
Caption: buy the ones that have
Caption: the sort of rectangular tips
Caption: yep chisel tip is that what it's called
Caption: cool there you go learn something
Caption: so you can use both edges right so my
Caption: little people here they just sort of
Caption: emulated it on my tablet is the wide one
Caption: to draw the bodies and a narrow one to
Caption: draw the heads and arms
Caption: so
Caption: all right
Caption: now this is a follow along
Caption: how to draw
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: please uh copy me if you want to
Caption: right
Caption: lines
Caption: these are simple
Caption: all right
Caption: easy
Caption: getting a bit harder
Caption: so these newland pens
Caption: have places for your
Caption: your fingers so you're always holding it
Caption: the right way so that tip touches the
Caption: paper the way it's supposed to
Caption: and i'm never good at making circles
Caption: circles but that's that one that one
Caption: turned out pretty good
Caption: all right
Caption: squiggly shapes
Caption: and
Caption: the last ones
Caption: are the other shapes
Caption: all right
Caption: my shark fin
Caption: and the letter u
Caption: so
Caption: if you can do all those shapes you can
Caption: draw
Caption: all of the
Caption: picablo
Caption: symbols
Caption: so
Caption: like that
Caption: all right very quick to draw something
Caption: and of course
Caption: shading helps
Caption: all right
Caption: so here's some other shapes
Caption: and again you'll see them all in
Caption: the picture shapes
Caption: and again
Caption: coloring shading
Caption: really changes the way they look
Caption: so let's draw some more
Caption: try these
Caption: okay and
Caption: for these
Caption: all right
Caption: our shark fin
Caption: okay
Caption: can you see i've got some no you can't
Caption: see it at all i've got some cheats on
Caption: there it's turned out it's very good
Caption: right so
Caption: a meeting between two people
Caption: now matsu
Caption: let me draw matsu
Caption: right but i'm going to do in a different
Caption: order i'm going to do the o
Caption: i'm going to do the m
Caption: i'm going to do a u
Caption: and a z
Caption: i'll do them on the screen
Caption: just check my pens working here
Caption: ah
Caption: okay
Caption: all right shading
Caption: now containers
Caption: when drawing containers and actually i
Caption: won't do it on the white on the on the
Caption: uh
Caption: right
Caption: draw the words
Caption: then draw the box around it if you draw
Caption: the box first your words won't fit
Caption: okay
Caption: all right
Caption: so you know just being able to all right
Caption: i'm drawing an architectural diagram and
Caption: i've got a secure area dropping a
Caption: dropping a lock
Caption: in a corner that's either locked or
Caption: unlocked you can draw that in 10 seconds
Caption: just to to make it you know
Caption: much easier than writing a secure zone
Caption: right or unsecured zone
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: i got these two books when i did the
Caption: training
Caption: and um they they basically talk through
Caption: lots of different techniques and shapes
Caption: and everything
Caption: i've just taken two photos just so you
Caption: can see some of the the symbols
Caption: i've drawn some already today you would
Caption: have seen
Caption: all right
Caption: so i'm going to draw people now
Caption: because this really comes down to how
Caption: much time you want to spend
Caption: so it could be as simple as an upside
Caption: down u and a line
Caption: and it looks like a person right a
Caption: little bit of shading helps it even if
Caption: you're doing that on the you know on the
Caption: run
Caption: you don't need to put arms but when we
Caption: draw stick figures you know our arms
Caption: don't come out of our tummies they come
Caption: out from under our necks
Caption: so you draw your arms at the top
Caption: you know you can start to do
Caption: actions like falling
Caption: pointing
Caption: right
Caption: the difference and in fact if if you're
Caption: looking at this guy
Caption: i copied
Caption: the guy that sort of like two to the
Caption: left and added the legs thickened his
Caption: arms and added the shading
Caption: and then sort of the stick figure guy i
Caption: like these from there i like how they
Caption: look so again the whiteboard people
Caption: these are very quick to draw using the
Caption: the pen with the chiseled
Caption: tip
Caption: and once you get the hang of drawing
Caption: people
Caption: then you can you know start to have them
Caption: do things so
Caption: a team being led on a journey in a boat
Caption: very
Caption: quick easy to to draw
Caption: is this kind of cool
Caption: all right
Caption: emotions
Caption: so
Caption: happy you don't need to put eyes for
Caption: happy
Caption: smiley face is really all you need
Caption: shock
Caption: pondering or thought
Caption: scared
Caption: if you don't want to draw faces you can
Caption: use symbolism as well right very easy to
Caption: uh to just give an idea you can you can
Caption: dress them up in hats
Caption: here
Caption: okay
Caption: now
Caption: if you have to
Caption: i'm going to say
Caption: don't draw
Caption: don't draw the stick man
Caption: it's just as easy to draw
Caption: two long legs
Caption: and a pair of arms
Caption: and it just comes across as a lot better
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: i'll save
Caption: i'll give this to you as a as a
Caption: jpeg afterwards as well
Caption: so writing is the next thing
Caption: and this is a thing i hate
Caption: so this is my writing
Caption: all right it's shocking
Caption: i can barely read it
Caption: and if i have to do something fast and
Caption: if i'm nervous like in a room of people
Caption: it gets even worse
Caption: so this is the be cable style of writing
Caption: okay and
Caption: the one thing is it's really compact
Caption: right much much more compact than my
Caption: handwriting so you can fit it
Caption: into flip charts really easily you can
Caption: get a lot more letters in so it's good
Caption: and the thing that makes it readable
Caption: is the really tall skinny
Caption: lowercase characters
Caption: now
Caption: sucks at this
Caption: this is the only font you have in
Caption: concept it's
Caption: helvetica or ariel and it's really long
Caption: and you don't get a choice it's one they
Caption: say fonts are coming later
Caption: next year but
Caption: so
Caption: that means i have to hand write
Caption: everything
Caption: so how do i do that when my writing
Caption: sucks
Caption: well
Caption: i've made my own font of all the letters
Caption: i use
Caption: and then
Caption: i copy paste
Caption: and manually
Caption: kern
Caption: and this this kind of sucks right
Caption: it kind of looks neat when you're
Caption: watching it and my teammates when they
Caption: see me doing this like that kind of you
Caption: know
Caption: that sort of satisfying videos that you
Caption: see where people are lining up the
Caption: letters and
Caption: other things so that's how i do this it
Caption: takes a long time
Caption: so i have a shortcut
Caption: and i have a
Caption: i use lucidchart as well
Caption: so
Caption: i've hand drawn a font that kinda
Caption: matches with
Caption: lucidchart
Caption: so i will sometimes use this instead of
Caption: the vocabulary font
Caption: and if i go to here
Caption: i didn't write that i went into
Caption: lucidchart i typed it in i saved it as a
Caption: transparent jpeg
Caption: i airdropped it onto the ipad i imported
Caption: it in and and dropped it into my diagram
Caption: and that's much faster than writing
Caption: paragraphs so if i have to write
Caption: paragraphs and put it in mostly i don't
Caption: because mostly i'm just drawing pictures
Caption: but if i have to that's the way i go
Caption: so
Caption: i'm really looking forward to concepts
Caption: supporting
Caption: more fonts
Caption: so actually going back to this
Caption: and the
Caption: um
Caption: it improves
Caption: memory right
Caption: if i were to bring up
Caption: the original flip chart
Caption: where was a helicopter
Caption: hands up
Caption: was it there number two
Caption: no hands up when i go to the right one
Caption: it was five yeah all right
Caption: had i written down the helicopters as a
Caption: list you probably wouldn't remember it
Caption: right
Caption: faces i'm almost done
Caption: so
Caption: ever want to draw this
Caption: step one draw the nose
Caption: then a smile
Caption: in here
Caption: 66 for eyes
Caption: some spiky hair
Caption: a chin
Caption: a neck
Caption: a collar
Caption: and shoulders
Caption: let's start that again
Caption: a nose
Caption: a mustache
Caption: the same ear
Caption: pair of glasses
Caption: the chin
Caption: make the neck
Caption: bolt head
Caption: right
Caption: and that's done
Caption: so
Caption: i'm kind of on time
Caption: who thinks i can do that
Caption: a few more all right that's good
Caption: so
Caption: um my journey
Caption: uh where are we
Caption: if i go back to now um
Caption: these are some diagrams that i've
Caption: started so
Caption: before the cable this is just a picture
Caption: from a whiteboard that
Caption: i've driven right drawn so
Caption: scribbling coloring in that sort of
Caption: thing
Caption: so
Caption: i tend to call this a light board where
Caption: you're
Caption: you're drawing with light on a black
Caption: background
Caption: after the cavallo
Caption: i switched to
Caption: a white board so this was my first
Caption: attempt
Caption: and this was in a week of of using the
Caption: cable i had redrawn
Caption: using the cavallo technique of shading
Caption: and coloring and the shapes etc
Caption: and then
Caption: this is kind of where i am now where i'm
Caption: i'm painstakingly neat
Caption: because i use these over and over and
Caption: over again it's like a it's like a book
Caption: you know
Caption: reading a story to a classroom where i'm
Caption: flipping pages so
Caption: um
Caption: i've put time into into something that
Caption: i'm going to use more than half a dozen
Caption: times or in this case a presentation i
Caption: do once but
Caption: anyway
Caption: so this is the same version
Caption: as a light board and visually i like the
Caption: the brightness of the imagery on black
Caption: but it's a it's a personal choice
Caption: now two weeks ago i gave a i gave a talk
Caption: on
Caption: data mesh at a
Caption: um
Caption: at an event in perth
Caption: and i'm not without stepping through it
Caption: like i stepped through this
Caption: this was
Caption: this was the presentation it's the first
Caption: time i sort of gave a presentation with
Caption: a tablet and a pen in front of a big
Caption: room
Caption: but
Caption: i tend to have slides in meetings where
Caption: i do you know agenda
Caption: um
Caption: uh go through problems where i might
Caption: document it um
Caption: uh so on and then you know the the
Caption: imagery and i'm just panning through
Caption: this i will if there are things that are
Caption: i need to bring in i'll bring them in as
Caption: a screenshot and just sort of frame them
Caption: in my
Caption: in my light boards you can see here my
Caption: people
Caption: okay
Caption: drawing interesting things like uh for
Caption: example
Caption: you know finding a balance between
Caption: central and decentralized governance
Caption: putting on a see-saw just
Caption: coming up with ideas about how you want
Caption: to portray something that you're you're
Caption: talking about so this is this was a
Caption: 20-minute talk and that was everything
Caption: that i had talked about and i'm going to
Caption: switch to a different
Caption: document now so this is going to go away
Caption: and i'm going to go in here
Caption: and this is this is my
Caption: storytelling
Caption: sort of
Caption: light board
Caption: so again i have my meeting hygiene
Caption: slides okay which i go through
Caption: uh history of confluent and apache kafka
Caption: and then i have my storytelling so all
Caption: this
Caption: i hand draw right
Caption: and i can bring them up and shut them
Caption: down depending on you know the story i
Caption: want to take there's about six stories
Caption: in this light board everything is turned
Caption: on
Caption: and
Caption: that's it so that's my presentation
Caption: questions
Caption: how much time do we have because i think
Caption: i'm probably are we at time
Caption: okay
Caption: um how do you get the ideas to generate
Caption: these stories
Caption: um
Caption: some of them are from so it might be a
Caption: presentation
Caption: or it might be a youtube video that has
Caption: a concept around let's just say it's you
Caption: know in my role i might need to talk
Caption: about
Caption: data warehouse modernization so i'll
Caption: take ideas and i will typically start
Caption: with a flow so i will scribble out
Caption: um in a layer within concepts just
Caption: wording or pictures as to what as to how
Caption: i want to
Caption: to make the story
Caption: and then i start from
Caption: the first part to the last part drawing
Caption: out the bits and pieces that i want to
Caption: talk about
Caption: and then just sort of crossing them off
Caption: as i go
Caption: all right and then once so what i
Caption: haven't done is i within concepts and
Caption: the way i've worked this is
Caption: i have all the different steps in my
Caption: story in different layers so what i was
Caption: doing with the pen and in fact what i
Caption: can show you
Caption: is
Caption: in concepts i can
Caption: it has a presentation mode which is good
Caption: what i'm going to go here is just to
Caption: mirror everything
Caption: and now you can see the toolbar so
Caption: over on the right in this one there are
Caption: layers and i can turn these on and off
Caption: as i go so building out that story once
Caption: i do one
Caption: new layer draw the new one new layer
Caption: draw the new one and also with the
Caption: with like if i'm drawing out icons so
Caption: here where i've got shading that's
Caption: potentially three layers so the um the
Caption: line around the outside the coloring on
Caption: the inside and then if i want to put a
Caption: shadow in there there's a layer
Caption: underneath which i then combine to that
Caption: object
Caption: i i think you might have answered this
Caption: but are these like reusable compounds
Caption: yes yes so what i do is um over you can
Caption: see my screen now on the left i have
Caption: things that i've imported into a toolbar
Caption: so i can
Caption: for example
Caption: if i
Caption: do that right
Caption: drop them in and use them so
Caption: the things i use more i drop in so it
Caption: makes it much easier to do and then
Caption: hence it becomes a lot faster than
Caption: drawing it on a on a piece of paper
Caption: a funny thing is so in concepts
Caption: a double tap is undo
Caption: and a triple tap is redo
Caption: and occasionally now if i'm doing this
Caption: and i stuff it up i'll do that
Caption: and it's like you know it it just
Caption: becomes natural once you start using
Caption: this all the time and you go into other
Caption: apps and i double tap i know i've got to
Caption: hit the undo button
Caption: hello
Caption: are you able to pre-configure the views
Caption: for the storytelling steps or are you
Caption: constantly another no i'm constantly
Caption: paging
Caption: i have thought about drawing them up and
Caption: then potentially using something like
Caption: prezi
Caption: but
Caption: when you're in a meeting it sometimes
Caption: you'll get taken off track
Caption: and doing that in a prezi is is a bit
Caption: hard
Caption: so
Caption: you just have to
Caption: i mean i'm kind of used to it and
Caption: it makes it interactive and i always get
Caption: lots of feedback at the end of the
Caption: meeting how did you do that right
Caption: hey
Caption: do you have like any tips for showing
Caption: how to do uh like
Caption: like cleaning up like relations between
Caption: things like this talks this is the
Caption: script of this
Caption: um
Caption: it kind of like how you do it on paper
Caption: so
Caption: um if i were to
Caption: to just draw something you know
Caption: actually that's let me so within here
Caption: you can see
Caption: you can change
Caption: um how things work so
Caption: you know
Caption: doing it very quickly but you can see in
Caption: this diagram how i've got like lots of
Caption: arrows and things that that's i
Caption: i have the
Caption: boxes inside other boxes um you know
Caption: connectors that you hand draw
Caption: is there any sort of thing you'd like to
Caption: sort of
Caption: go beyond that or
Caption: no it's um so one of the things i do is
Caption: i'll draw something and i think well
Caption: that doesn't fit
Caption: so then what i need to do is you know
Caption: i'll be
Caption: selecting
Caption: large areas
Caption: and then i have to wait for that because
Caption: that's quite complex
Caption: and then i'll move them around
Caption: right so
Caption: quite often when i'm doing the drawings
Caption: it doesn't work the way i want it and
Caption: then i have to start reorganizing the
Caption: puzzle
Caption: you heard of the tool mirror yes
Caption: i'm sorry yeah so mirror is very good
Caption: for
Caption: those online where you've got lots of
Caption: people working um at the same time but
Caption: most of those people are working with a
Caption: mouse right you're putting a post-it
Caption: note on a piece of paper and you're
Caption: drawing drawing with a mouse is so hard
Caption: yeah yeah
Caption: but mirror's cool it is right for
Caption: so how do you share your slides after
Caption: presentations um so after i've um i've
Caption: done something and typically what i'll
Caption: do is i'll have a layer in here which is
Caption: where i put my notes so actions and
Caption: everything else
Caption: it's export
Caption: choose the format so jpeg
Caption: whether it's a selection or the entire
Caption: drawing whether i want
Caption: a black or or white background the
Caption: resolution and then i'll air drop it to
Caption: my
Caption: mac and send it out as a pdf
Caption: so what i will do
Caption: um
Caption: if if you want this
Caption: you can
Caption: reach out to me on linkedin or i don't
Caption: know how is there a way of putting
Caption: giving the presentations out afterwards
Caption: yep so i'll
Caption: export this as a jpeg at the end
Caption: good um thanks everyone so much please
Caption: give another round of applause for the
Caption: amazing film
Caption: thank you
Caption: it's now morning tea so go out grab
Caption: yourself a coffee something to eat talks
Caption: resume at 11 25.
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you
Caption: want yeah
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now zero it's an identity
Caption: platform fast easy logins just what the
Caption: boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's stephen
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: nice
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hi
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: canada needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: hi
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: this office nerd's nerding what we're
Caption: doing is we're talking to people all
Caption: over the world because we're stuck in
Caption: our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my goal sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the barrack completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn it does not
Caption: reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: there it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top down
Caption: of testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience
Caption: and boost your personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: pleasure to introduce macklin
Caption: hartley to you today
Caption: he is a full stack engineer who's been
Caption: in the industry for nearly 10 years
Caption: so fair bit of experience there and he
Caption: speaks about a range of topics including
Caption: accessibility cueing theory continuous
Caption: delivery and feature toggling and this
Caption: is his third speaking engagement ddd
Caption: and he's going to be talking to you
Caption: about how fast is your website really so
Caption: please round of applause for macklin
Caption: thank you
Caption: is this working
Caption: yep
Caption: all right so
Caption: how fast is your website really that's a
Caption: question i'm gonna ask today how many
Caption: people build fast websites
Caption: you all build slow websites
Caption: that's probably why you're here i guess
Caption: right
Caption: cool um
Caption: how do you know if your website's fast
Caption: though i kind of was bill built this
Caption: slide under the assumption that everyone
Caption: will put their hands up but that's okay
Caption: how do we even know that's probably the
Caption: question that we need to ask at the
Caption: moment
Caption: so spoiler alert this is how you know
Caption: this is this is the answer you need to
Caption: have user-centric performance metrics
Caption: you need to capture those metrics from
Caption: real devices and you need to have
Caption: continuous observability over those
Caption: metrics so that's that's the whole talk
Caption: right um
Caption: no that's that's the that's the end of
Caption: the talk i'm going to get to that point
Caption: but we're going to figure out how to get
Caption: there right
Caption: um just before i continue on one thing
Caption: that this talk is not going to be is how
Caption: to actually tune for better for
Caption: performance um how to do web performance
Caption: tuning um that's probably a whole other
Caption: talk in itself
Caption: and actually there's tons of tips like
Caption: google will give you heaps of tips on
Caption: how to do that so we'll we'll separate
Caption: that out of this talk
Caption: we're just going to figure out how to
Caption: actually measure it first
Caption: and then we'll go from there
Caption: so let's start by forgetting everything
Caption: we actually know about web performance
Caption: monitoring and we'll start from scratch
Caption: i like the idea of starting somewhere
Caption: really naive and then kind of building
Caption: up building up from there so what we're
Caption: going to do is do the simplest thing
Caption: that i can probably think of which is
Caption: just on on that page load event um this
Caption: is an event that's available to you in
Caption: the browser um we're just going to track
Caption: our performance there so this would be
Caption: code that you can actually run
Caption: and we can see our page took 729
Caption: milliseconds to load
Caption: so that's nice
Caption: except it kind of falls apart because
Caption: the moment we look in the performance
Caption: inspector which is the tool that's
Caption: available inside chrome you can see the
Caption: the red l there that's your page load
Caption: event and you can actually see that
Caption: stuff's happening on either side of that
Caption: event and actually most of it's
Caption: happening on the wrong side so that's
Caption: not telling us anything useful
Caption: basically more of the stuff is happening
Caption: after that event
Caption: so we've got to try and fix that
Caption: one thing we could do is we could use
Caption: the new navigation timing api so it's a
Caption: bit more modern than just sort of
Caption: running a page load event
Caption: um
Caption: that is okay but really that's just
Caption: giving us a whole lot of numbers that
Caption: are about as meaningless as the page
Caption: load event that's not telling us
Caption: anything useful when i get
Caption: uh dom content loaded event end
Caption: what does that mean what does that mean
Caption: for the user what does that look like
Caption: so a bunch of smart big brain people
Caption: have gotten together and actually uh
Caption: all realized that we all have the same
Caption: problem
Caption: and they put together the w3c web
Caption: performance working group
Caption: and this group
Caption: came together and came up with a they
Caption: coined a term called user-centric
Caption: performance or user-centric performance
Caption: metrics
Caption: so what are those
Caption: they're centered around a couple of
Caption: different things
Caption: you've got perceived load speed that's
Caption: as perceived as in as best as we can
Caption: represent the load speed perceived by
Caption: the user
Caption: load responsiveness uh which is just how
Caption: fast that that process goes for
Caption: runtime responsiveness which is after
Caption: it's loaded how fast is your website
Caption: and then two other things visual
Caption: stability and smoothness which are less
Caption: about performance but still really
Caption: important
Caption: and out of that who's seen these before
Caption: these metrics yep web vitals
Caption: a number of metrics with abbreviations
Caption: that are sometimes hard to remember um
Caption: that are the key metrics for measuring
Caption: web performance really handy
Caption: i'm going to go through all of these
Caption: really quickly i i know a lot of you
Caption: people put your hands up saying that
Caption: they've seen these before
Caption: so i won't spend too long on them but
Caption: we're going to go through what each one
Caption: of these means just quickly so time to
Caption: first byte is the time between when the
Caption: browser requests the page and when it
Caption: receives the first bite of information
Caption: back and it's kind of just all of the
Caption: stuff that's happening before your page
Caption: loads
Caption: there's actually quite a lot of it
Caption: usually
Caption: a lot of this happens very very quickly
Caption: so it's almost imperceptible but a
Caption: number of things can actually affect how
Caption: long this process takes so it's really
Caption: important to measure that
Caption: google
Caption: who
Caption: i guess are big and heavily involved in
Caption: the w3c working web performance working
Caption: group
Caption: suggests that time to first bite should
Caption: be under 800 milliseconds that's a good
Caption: score but anything over 1.8 seconds is
Caption: poor and needs improvement
Caption: next up we have first contentful paint
Caption: this is the time from when the page
Caption: starts loading to any any part of the
Caption: page is rendered on the screen so this
Caption: is going from a white box in your
Caption: browser to the first time anything
Caption: appears on the screen
Caption: it looks a bit like this
Caption: so we can see we captured fcp when that
Caption: first part of the result comes up on the
Caption: top um google is really convenient for
Caption: testing this stuff because they stream
Caption: these results back to you so you slow it
Caption: down slightly and you can actually
Caption: capture this
Caption: now we can see at the top there fcps 0.5
Caption: seconds
Caption: fcp should be anywhere between
Caption: should be below 1.8 seconds if you can
Caption: help it anything above 3 seconds is too
Caption: long and it needs improvement
Caption: next up you have lcp or largest content
Caption: for paint
Caption: this is tracking how many seconds it
Caption: takes for the largest
Caption: item or the largest
Caption: data most most data intensive
Caption: element above the fault element takes to
Caption: load
Caption: so it looks like this we can actually
Caption: see it shifts as this page loads um
Caption: and we're looking at the the largest
Caption: uh we're tracking
Caption: oops we're tracking the largest uh
Caption: element on the page at a given
Caption: time let's pick that up
Caption: so you can see
Caption: uh lcp shifts from from the sort of the
Caption: top of the bottom of the page is
Caption: actually um the fcp at the very
Caption: beginning
Caption: but then as the largest as we kind of
Caption: uncover the largest element as we go
Caption: that fcp score changes and at the end we
Caption: calculate it at 1.6 seconds
Caption: largest content for paint should be
Caption: under 2.5 seconds if you can help it
Caption: and anything over 4 seconds is too long
Caption: then you have some other metrics as well
Caption: less associated with load times but
Caption: still really important um this one's
Caption: called first input delay it's the time
Caption: for the first interaction on the page um
Caption: the first time your user clicks anything
Caption: google targeted the first time the user
Caption: clicks anything because uh quite often
Caption: while your page is loading it's quite a
Caption: data intensive cpu intensive exercise
Caption: and if your user clicks anything while
Caption: that's happening you are likely to see
Caption: some sort of delay or incur some sort of
Caption: sort of uh less than ideal experience
Caption: so they focused on that first input
Caption: it looks a little bit like this
Caption: usually it's quite imperceptible that
Caption: the target scores are very low so this
Caption: is a bit more of a contrived example
Caption: but you can click that button and then
Caption: there's an input delay there and we
Caption: track that
Caption: like i was saying
Caption: quite quite low target scores there
Caption: usually imperceptible like 100
Caption: milliseconds is quite imperceptible
Caption: a good score is 100 milliseconds
Caption: anything over 300 is too long
Caption: next up this is a fairly new metric
Caption: called interaction to next paint and the
Caption: way to think about this one is its first
Caption: input delay
Caption: calculated slightly differently but over
Caption: the course of the entire interaction
Caption: with the page so not just the first
Caption: interaction but every interaction on the
Caption: page every button you click
Caption: every carousel you scroll and stuff like
Caption: that
Caption: interaction to next paint should be
Caption: under 200 milliseconds if you can help
Caption: it um
Caption: anything over
Caption: every anything over half a second is too
Caption: long
Caption: now there's a slide missing there but
Caption: that's all right uh cumulative layout
Caption: shift is the last one uh this one is a
Caption: little bit a little bit different but i
Caption: think it's still a really important
Caption: metric it's not so much about web
Caption: performance uh as as much it is as much
Caption: it is about sort of visual stability
Caption: um the way
Caption: we can perceive
Caption: cumulative layout shift um this is why i
Caption: think it's really important because
Caption: these are really annoying and they suck
Caption: and no user likes this when this happens
Caption: um this is maybe a less disastrous
Caption: example but
Caption: no missing a slide there too cool
Caption: there was a i think there was a famous
Caption: example where um there was a layout
Caption: shift on a
Caption: on a page with a nuclear missile alert
Caption: test system and they clicked the wrong
Caption: one that's that's the picture i had but
Caption: it's gone so
Caption: um this is a score between zero and one
Caption: so it's sort of a calculated score i
Caption: think of it more of like a percentage
Caption: but i don't know if that's actually what
Caption: it's meant to represent but anything
Caption: below 0.1 or 10
Caption: is good
Caption: uh anything over 25 or 0.25
Caption: probably needs some work it's probably
Caption: got too many of those shifting
Caption: components that are getting in the way
Caption: annoying your users
Caption: so
Caption: a number of these metrics not all of
Caption: them make up what google called the core
Caption: web vitals
Caption: you can see here largest contentful
Caption: paint and first input delay and
Caption: cumulative layout shift
Caption: they make up actually what google
Caption: uh uses to decide whether where your
Caption: search engine ranking is um if you have
Caption: uh if you're somewhere on a search
Caption: engine page
Caption: typically you can move up that search
Caption: and result if you have a faster website
Caption: so there's actually material benefit
Caption: here a commercial benefit
Caption: in that if you improve the performance
Caption: of your site you actually
Caption: uh get get improved performance sort of
Caption: in in your externalities for example
Caption: um i want to talk about largest
Caption: contentful paint why do they choose that
Caption: one
Caption: because these metrics aren't they don't
Caption: have atomicity so
Caption: you might have noticed when we went
Caption: through our examples before
Caption: um time to first by time to first bite
Caption: the way it's calculated usually means um
Caption: you'll get a score that is below first
Caption: contentful pain and a score that is
Caption: below your largest contentful pain
Caption: sometimes the first contentful and
Caption: largest contentful paint will be the
Caption: same that's probably a good thing
Caption: but what this means is tracking all of
Caption: these three together
Caption: we can actually sort of look at the
Caption: differences between them and identify
Caption: which one is having the most impact on
Caption: your web performance so for example if
Caption: you have a high very high number for
Caption: time to first bite that's usually an
Caption: indicator that
Caption: your user's very far away from where
Caption: your web page is being served from you
Caption: can improve that by bringing them closer
Caption: together
Caption: whereas if for example if your time to
Caption: first bite is really good
Caption: but you've got a kind of larger gap to
Caption: first content footprint sort of in this
Caption: case here and then a very large gap to
Caption: the largest contentful paint um we're
Caption: able to transfer the javascript and the
Caption: html onto the page very very quickly but
Caption: it takes a long time to process that
Caption: pass the javascript and render it so
Caption: that's where you'd probably want to set
Caption: your focus
Caption: and setting your focus on stuff like
Caption: this
Caption: is really good like we have case studies
Caption: that actually prove that there is
Caption: commercial benefit to doing this
Caption: vodafone is a really good example
Caption: vodafone's huge so eight percent of
Caption: sales is an astronomically high number
Caption: but eight percent more sales when they
Caption: increase their performance on largest
Caption: contentful pain
Caption: so i think we know how to get
Caption: user-centric performance metrics now we
Caption: know what they are at least
Caption: so we can tick that box
Caption: let's figure out now how to actually
Caption: capture these metrics
Caption: so there's a couple of different ways
Caption: that we can capture them
Caption: you've got ad hoc testing synthetic
Caption: monitoring and then real user monitoring
Caption: so i'm going to go into each one of
Caption: those
Caption: ad hoc testing who's used lighthouse for
Caption: google chrome before
Caption: nice this side of the room
Caption: i'll focus my attention this way then
Caption: so lighthouse for google chrome is a
Caption: tool built in built into google chrome
Caption: that allows you to test any web page
Caption: probably more likely your own the one
Caption: that you manage
Caption: and it will give you back those those
Caption: web vital scores you can see them it's
Caption: probably kind of small but they're those
Caption: numbers in the bottom right corner
Caption: um it's tracked uh first contentful
Caption: paint largest can contentful paint all
Caption: of those other metrics
Caption: um this is really handy um it's
Caption: obviously a free tool um
Caption: that you obviously a free tool that you
Caption: can like everyone already has so really
Caption: good start using that um but perhaps a
Caption: better example is this tool here also
Caption: provided by google this will run
Caption: a lighthouse on your behalf
Caption: on a device
Caption: that is not a desktop computer
Caption: so this makes a huge difference because
Caption: the performance profile of a mobile
Caption: device which is what this will run on um
Caption: it makes a significant difference
Caption: to the score and is actually probably
Caption: more realistic and uh representative of
Caption: real world traffic most of your users
Caption: are going to come from mobile devices
Caption: the other interesting thing about this
Caption: is um this will run in a data center in
Caption: the united states so if the majority of
Caption: your customers are there and not here
Caption: this is going to be more representative
Caption: of that too
Caption: so this ad hoc testing this is really
Caption: great it's free anyone can do this and i
Caption: suggest and recommend that people do
Caption: this
Caption: when you've got if you've got a website
Caption: you should be kind of testing the
Caption: performance and tracking all of this
Caption: stuff there's no setup required everyone
Caption: has google chrome even if you don't use
Caption: it you probably got it
Caption: but these are only good for once off
Caption: manual tests it's it's clicking around
Caption: testing stuff we don't have any
Caption: automation here
Caption: um and they're also
Caption: even though
Caption: uh the the web performance uh the the
Caption: web.dev slash measure that tool
Caption: runs in a us data center on a mobile
Caption: device they still don't really represent
Caption: real world traffic
Caption: i'll get back to that in a minute
Caption: one of our other options is synthetic
Caption: monitoring so this is an example of one
Caption: tool
Caption: these are really cool people that build
Caption: this they're based in australia
Caption: caliber and what we're actually looking
Caption: at here is a pull request a comment on a
Caption: pull request
Caption: so the way this tool is set up is every
Caption: time you create a pull request
Caption: you can set it up to
Caption: uh
Caption: on a deployed version of of this change
Caption: uh run run a web web vitals test i think
Caption: it runs it just runs lighthouse but on
Caption: your behalf it will run on multiple
Caption: different devices so it will run on
Caption: desktops but multiple different um
Caption: android and ios devices for you as well
Caption: we check that and it can you can choose
Caption: all the locations and stuff like that
Caption: that you run on so it's a bit more
Caption: representative of your railroad traffic
Caption: again
Caption: so this is this is probably a better
Caption: tool um
Caption: if you want to sort of take the next
Caption: step
Caption: you've got your continuous integration
Caption: continuous delivery automation through
Caption: those pull request checks
Caption: so that allows you if you're doing the
Caption: regular pull request to monitor change
Caption: over time
Caption: unfortunately this tool is not free you
Caption: do have to pay a little bit to use it
Caption: um and it's still not representative of
Caption: real world traffic so we've got more
Caption: devices now um but at the end of the day
Caption: those devices are still running in data
Caption: centers
Caption: and we're kind of
Caption: assuming that's how it's going to behave
Caption: on the real world but it's still not the
Caption: real world like i think we can do better
Caption: why do i think this is important so
Caption: if we look at browser engines uh we
Caption: might be mistaken into thinking that
Caption: there's not a whole lot of diversity
Caption: there so you've got
Caption: webkit-based devices this is a
Caption: traffic from a website that i i
Caption: currently kind of maintain um so don't
Caption: know this is 100 accurate to i like
Caption: global statistics um but
Caption: if we look at browser engines you've got
Caption: you've got webkit so every single ios
Caption: device um as well as some mac os desktop
Caption: devices we'll be running webkit um i say
Caption: every single ios device if you've got
Caption: google chrome on your iphone it's
Caption: actually webkit it's not google chrome
Caption: and then the rest of it is blink so same
Caption: same browser engine as google chrome
Caption: if you're running microsoft edge you've
Caption: got that so not a whole lot of diversity
Caption: there
Caption: same with form factor we're down to sort
Caption: of a two-speed world you've got desktop
Caption: devices and mobile devices you've got a
Caption: small sliver there for tvs or something
Caption: tablets right
Caption: but i think this is probably a naive way
Caption: to look at it so you might look at these
Caption: and go i really only need to test on an
Caption: iphone
Caption: and maybe one android device and a
Caption: windows desktop maybe that should be
Caption: enough
Caption: i don't think that's good enough
Caption: let's have a look at um this is a a
Caption: graph showing the the single core scores
Caption: of devices
Caption: a wide range of devices mobile devices
Caption: um it goes up to
Caption: 2020
Caption: so i think there's been some shifts as
Caption: well but the really interesting thing
Caption: this is telling us is there's a huge
Caption: like massive difference in performance
Caption: between top-end devices and low-end
Caption: devices and the problem here is the
Caption: majority of your users aren't running
Caption: those top-end devices this is like if
Caption: you're um who here has an iphone and is
Caption: running tests on it regularly cool one
Caption: person
Caption: um
Caption: this one person i can tell you that
Caption: maybe uh what you're doing is not
Caption: representative of what the majority of
Caption: your users are experiencing so
Caption: to put it another way um and this is
Caption: obviously with old data we've got a new
Caption: iphone that's just come out so this is
Caption: going to change again um the difference
Caption: in performance between those two devices
Caption: is so significant that uh
Caption: like this we've got a coin we've got a
Caption: term that's been coined for this it's
Caption: called the performance inequality gap
Caption: um
Caption: yeah that that's a that's a big
Caption: difference there um that was actually
Caption: coined by by this guy he's uh he does
Caption: some really interesting talks on that
Caption: i've got some links at the end to the
Caption: talks that this guy's done before
Caption: um
Caption: he he has a really interesting part on
Caption: his talk where
Caption: uh he's running these performance ben uh
Caption: performance benchmarks on these devices
Caption: um and
Caption: just to sort of add add to this as well
Caption: um
Caption: he's got
Caption: a nexus 5x he's tested at once and then
Caption: he puts it on top of a block of ice
Caption: and that that device now performs 15
Caption: faster so that's really interesting this
Caption: now means that environment the
Caption: environment which you run your your uh
Caption: website and and these benchmarks are
Caption: working in
Caption: also changes performance so that that
Caption: score that you had before that could be
Caption: 15 higher or 15 lower
Caption: um and this isn't this isn't just sort
Caption: of like no one's actually running their
Caption: devices on a block of ice but if you're
Caption: outside on a 40 degree day in perth you
Caption: could actually have users that are
Caption: experiencing your your site with 15 less
Caption: performance
Caption: so this is this is a real thing that
Caption: does come up when we're talking about
Caption: real world sort of metrics and reward
Caption: tracking
Caption: another thing that's really important is
Caption: i think a lot of us
Caption: work under the assumption that
Caption: networks are widely widely a lot faster
Caption: and a lot more capable than they've ever
Caption: been 4g itself is very widely available
Caption: that's great that's a bit of a miracle
Caption: actually because it's pulling us forward
Caption: we have a significant
Caption: reduction in in the use of like our sort
Caption: of four second budget four seconds is
Caption: for lcp um we've got
Caption: we've made huge strides and and
Caption: uh all sites are generally a lot better
Caption: performing for this
Caption: um but that only works under the
Caption: assumption that 4g networks are evenly
Caption: distributed which they're not
Caption: if we look at the sort of variance
Caption: within wa in 4g network speeds at the
Caption: low end you've got about 18 megabytes
Caption: per second and at the high end
Caption: you're talking almost 10 times higher
Caption: than that
Caption: same goes for latency
Caption: latency can differ very significantly
Caption: particularly on for 4g networks 4g by
Caption: the way networks the majority of devices
Caption: are browsing on as well so
Caption: uh that that is where you're going to
Caption: see the majority of your devices and the
Caption: majority of of your users with their
Caption: devices are going to be experiencing
Caption: this sort of variance in performance
Caption: so hopefully that tells you that we
Caption: probably need to actually start
Caption: monitoring on real devices so that we
Caption: can account for
Caption: environmental factors different 4g
Caption: networks and different temperatures as
Caption: it turns out as well as different cpu
Caption: performance on devices
Caption: so what is real user monitoring
Caption: real user monitoring is capturing
Caption: performance metrics directly from
Caption: devices so that we can observe
Caption: differences in functionality reliability
Caption: and responsiveness
Caption: so an example of how to do
Caption: real user monitoring
Caption: might be the chrome user experience
Caption: report
Caption: so
Caption: i think we all know that chrome
Caption: while you're browsing the internet is
Caption: doing all sorts of tracking
Caption: some of it's good some of it's not so
Caption: good this is maybe one of the
Caption: the gooder ones i'd say um
Caption: every single website you visit google is
Caption: sending uh it's it's anonymizing and
Caption: then sending um
Caption: web vitals metrics to itself it collates
Caption: all of those metrics and makes this data
Caption: set completely free and available to you
Caption: so you can pull down this data set now
Caption: for a site that you manage
Caption: and you can see how it's performing on
Caption: real-world devices
Caption: across the internet
Caption: the chrome user experience report is
Caption: great because it's free you can see i
Caption: can go and see the chrome user
Caption: experience report for google.com or
Caption: facebook.com it's widely available
Caption: it does do real user monitoring so cool
Caption: fix that box
Caption: the one downside is that uh it doesn't
Caption: give you these metrics in real time so
Caption: you can pull this report once a month
Caption: um that's that's a bit unfortunate
Caption: because if we wanted to if we made a
Caption: change and we were worried about the
Caption: performance
Caption: that feedback loop is too long
Caption: what happens there is uh you might make
Caption: a sort of a performance regression
Caption: you incur
Caption: the cost of that performance regression
Caption: for entire month before knowing that
Caption: you've done that and then then you have
Caption: to go and try and figure out what caused
Caption: that a month later so that's not ideal
Caption: the other thing is this only profiles
Caption: google chrome devices so you don't get
Caption: realistic real user monitoring for ios
Caption: devices based on webkit and actually not
Caption: even all chrome devices um just google
Caption: chrome so not like blink uh microsoft
Caption: edge or anything like that they're not
Caption: sending data to google for you
Caption: so it's not representing everyone
Caption: here's another tool um this kind of
Caption: fixes the uh
Caption: with the
Caption: google chrome user experience report um
Caption: there's a couple of hoops you have to
Caption: jump through you have to get a google
Caption: account and then use this data studio
Caption: thing um set it up this kind of just
Caption: makes this a whole lot easier you don't
Caption: have to create an account or anything
Caption: like that you can just plug in a site
Caption: right now anyone here could just do this
Caption: in about two seconds it's made by the
Caption: caliber people too
Caption: and
Caption: i've been told to put the sponsor slide
Caption: either at the beginning or the end so
Caption: the ddd people are probably panicking
Caption: now because i'm about halfway through
Caption: and i've got the slide here like is he
Caption: finished
Caption: now um
Caption: i've decided to do something probably
Caption: that might get me a little bit in
Caption: trouble but i'm going to do a sponsor
Caption: leaderboard so i'm going to go through
Caption: all of the sponsors to tell you how fast
Caption: your sites are going to perform
Caption: yeah yeah all right so um
Caption: just some ground rules when we start um
Caption: this is how i'm going to run the tool
Caption: i'm going to run it across the whole
Caption: domain you tend to get better results
Caption: it's more representative of everything
Caption: that's going on
Caption: as well as
Caption: there are some sites that aren't going
Caption: to have enough traffic so you need i
Caption: think at least a thousand visits on
Caption: google chrome per month so some of them
Caption: are going to get missed out there
Caption: and the other thing is i'm going to
Caption: order this dashboard um in
Caption: descending order from
Caption: the lcp metric because i think that
Caption: one's most important we touched on that
Caption: before the
Caption: case study for vodafone that tends to be
Caption: the one that's tied to commercial
Caption: benefit so we're gonna go that one
Caption: so a couple of people got off the hook
Caption: um didn't get enough traffic so
Caption: good for them
Caption: maybe next year
Caption: uh and this one's a little bit
Caption: embarrassing so i i work for one of
Caption: these companies it's the one on number
Caption: 20 there so what happened there um i can
Caption: i can explain that and i think i will um
Caption: that website there is more so a
Caption: recruitment tool than it is the website
Caption: that we uh derive commercial benefit
Caption: from so
Caption: that's why that's like that also uh i
Caption: have nothing to do with that one so
Caption: that's probably why it's like that
Caption: um some other interesting scores here we
Caption: have the lowest score obviously for fcp
Caption: and lcp on this on this dashboard really
Caption: interesting though that for insight not
Caption: sure what happened um
Caption: the fcp is larger than the lcp so a bit
Caption: confusing i don't think that's actually
Caption: possible maybe that's a dud result scrub
Caption: that off now we're last great
Caption: there's also a zero score for cumulative
Caption: layout shift here so good good on family
Caption: zone for doing that
Caption: let's move up the board here
Caption: some more interesting results
Caption: uh what have we got um planet testing
Caption: has a uh interesting score for
Caption: cumulative layout shift of one i'm not
Caption: sure what to make of that um that's a
Caption: bit odd to me maybe that's just a bad
Caption: result as well
Caption: we've got bunnings along the middle
Caption: there um i should say that uh when i'm
Caption: identifying this stuff obviously this is
Caption: this could be taken or construed as a
Caption: bit of a roast um but i also say this is
Caption: an opportunity for improvement until you
Caption: see something like this
Caption: anyone work for bunnings
Caption: cool at the back this is a really
Caption: there's probably something really simple
Caption: that's that's causing something like
Caption: this especially if it's right across the
Caption: board so there might be opportunity for
Caption: improvement uh here um have a quick look
Caption: at it
Caption: it might sort of highlight something uh
Caption: that you hadn't seen before
Caption: uh we've also got the best score for
Caption: first input delay from telstra purple
Caption: here so good for them and i i've got an
Caption: interesting result here as well so bank
Caption: west best score for time to first buy
Caption: awesome
Caption: better than aws
Caption: so global
Caption: globally redundant
Caption: uh
Caption: massive network probably the largest
Caption: single network in in history ever made
Caption: and bankwest dingy little bank from
Caption: perth better time to first bite so
Caption: whatever whatever the bankwest people
Caption: are doing is probably pretty good
Caption: yeah yeah so actually that is a good
Caption: point um data center and customers
Caption: majority in perth so
Caption: that's probably where that's coming from
Caption: obviously aws much more distributed so
Caption: now and here's the final result so
Caption: who saw that one coming uh dd perth
Caption: number two there's obviously some really
Caption: smart people putting that one together
Caption: the only green across-the-board score
Caption: was versace so good job to them and then
Caption: number one score is github
Caption: um anyone have any theories about why
Caption: github's number one aside from massive
Caption: investment in web performance
Caption: race
Caption: yep
Caption: so for anyone who didn't hear yeah
Caption: reese's mom doesn't use github as it
Caption: turns out i kind of i kind of assumed
Caption: she did but
Caption: um
Caption: also yeah uh desktop devices majority of
Caption: people with like high powered devices
Caption: largely text-based pretty much all tech
Caption: space as well that tends to help so
Caption: largest contentful paint um if you've
Caption: got images on the page you'll be
Caption: impacted by that so some of these scores
Caption: as well should be mentioned that um take
Caption: them with a bit of a grain of salt it's
Caption: like it's not that github is doing
Caption: something particularly special sometimes
Caption: it's actually more more the user base
Caption: themselves
Caption: but again yeah plenty of opportunity for
Caption: improvement here as well particularly if
Caption: you've got some of the results on this
Caption: sort of part of the board as well um
Caption: there might be something really simple
Caption: i'm not going to talk about that in this
Caption: talk though that's probably the next one
Caption: see you next year
Caption: all right so we figured out how to
Caption: capture metrics from end user devices
Caption: there's a number of really easy ways to
Caption: do it
Caption: but we're still missing continuous
Caption: observability so we've got our chrome
Caption: user experience report we can get these
Caption: we can get this data
Caption: but we can get it once a month so that's
Caption: not really good enough we need to be
Caption: able to see this data at real time
Caption: now here's a bit of a our progress as we
Caption: go here so you can see
Caption: we're improving along the way there but
Caption: we don't currently have that solution
Caption: that gives us all three we haven't quite
Caption: worked that out yet
Caption: so if we if we can't find an off shelf
Caption: off the shelf tool um why don't we just
Caption: ask ourselves
Caption: is it really that hard to build yourself
Caption: an analytics service can we build it
Caption: ourselves we might as well have a try
Caption: we've been through all the tools nothing
Caption: seems to be quite hitting the mark on
Caption: all three
Caption: uh actually turns out it's really easy
Caption: so
Caption: you can grab this library this is the
Caption: web vitals library it's the same
Caption: library that i guess they built into
Caption: google chrome it can give you the same
Caption: scores but you can run javascript you
Caption: can pull that down and um
Caption: it looks a bit but a little bit like
Caption: this you can just import a bunch of
Caption: functions you can add callbacks to them
Caption: that send to analytics function i'll get
Caption: to that in a sec but um we can also
Caption: while we're here if we're going to send
Caption: something to our little analytics
Caption: service we can capture some other stuff
Caption: as well so javascript errors
Caption: content security policy violations we
Caption: can send all of that stuff down there
Caption: that center analytics function looks
Caption: like this
Caption: uh it maybe looks a little i've got i've
Caption: got prettier run over this so maybe
Caption: looks a little bit hard to read
Caption: it just sends a sends a request down to
Caption: a server so we can start reporting these
Caption: metrics that navigator.sendbeacon way is
Caption: a better better way to send metrics like
Caption: this because it can
Caption: finish the request
Caption: after your or somewhat after your page
Caption: unloads um goes to the next page so if
Caption: your user clicks on on something and you
Caption: really want to quickly report a metric
Caption: there or an error or something like that
Caption: that's more likely to capture it but
Caption: let's fall back to fetch just in case
Caption: and
Caption: i'm doing a bit of like i'm doing a bit
Caption: of code golf here so i've tried to
Caption: compress it all into one page but this
Caption: is the entire server this is the whole
Caption: thing
Caption: um so really
Caption: 24 lines of code is all it took
Caption: we can see here that we're importing
Caption: this prom client library which is the
Caption: prometheus library we'll get to that in
Caption: a minute
Caption: we can set up a metrics like this
Caption: we're using summary metrics so that
Caption: allows us to observe uh time
Caption: distributions
Caption: and then that's the service just an
Caption: express web server depending on which
Caption: metric we get back
Caption: we'll just observe each one of those
Caption: so then moving on from there we've got
Caption: our analytics server in the middle um
Caption: and then because it's just a
Caption: really simple web server we don't have
Caption: um
Caption: it's not sort of um paired with a
Caption: database there's no persistence or
Caption: anything like that we can keep our
Caption: metrics in memory and the way of doing
Caption: this with prometheus is it's pull-based
Caption: so that's polling on a continuous basis
Caption: our analytics service for the latest
Caption: version of the metrics keeping track of
Caption: that
Caption: and then we've got grafana slapped on
Caption: top of that because grafina has really
Caption: nice pretty graphs which we'll show in a
Caption: minute
Caption: but this is dead simple and because we
Caption: rolled our own analytics service
Caption: i'm not going to tell you all to use
Caption: prometheus and grafana that's what i use
Caption: but there's nothing stopping you from
Caption: hooking this up to honeycomb or sending
Caption: this data to new relic if you wanted to
Caption: there's about a million different
Caption: options for this and you can send it
Caption: wherever you want and because you've
Caption: written your own code for this
Caption: that is completely up to you
Caption: so here's another example where we might
Caption: want to
Caption: store our metrics for more long-term use
Caption: so you've got amazon kinesis fire hose
Caption: and s3 and then you can use snowflake to
Caption: run queries over that data
Caption: um dead simple also there's probably 15
Caption: 000 different ways to do this as well
Caption: this is just one example
Caption: and i i don't we don't do this yet but
Caption: um yeah i can i can see there being
Caption: value and sort of having a long long
Caption: term trends for those metrics rather
Caption: than something that lives in memory so
Caption: as soon as those
Caption: containers are dead then you have to
Caption: start again
Caption: and this is what we end up with so this
Caption: is
Caption: grafana a
Caption: quick video from grafana we're tracking
Caption: all of those metrics we've got
Caption: um an instant instantaneous score so
Caption: that's really helpful for
Caption: um if we've made a quick change we can
Caption: just look at that and see if that
Caption: number's gone up we can observe trends
Caption: over time i've got heat maps there so
Caption: i've got a um
Caption: a histogram type
Caption: uh metric as well and that allows us to
Caption: sort of see that distribution
Caption: over time and we can kind of observe any
Caption: of those trends there so that's really
Caption: useful i really like the one in the
Caption: bottom right as well those are tied to
Caption: the actual performance scores
Caption: that i showed you before so
Caption: green is uh in that good space and then
Caption: anything above that is red
Caption: we can see how often we're going into
Caption: that red there so that's really really
Caption: helpful too
Caption: if you remember we
Caption: also sent some other stuff to our
Caption: analytics service so
Caption: now that we've got this this server we
Caption: can kind of start reporting on
Caption: everything that's going on as well so
Caption: i've got some geo-location stuff in
Caption: there which devices
Caption: people are using because we have our own
Caption: analytics server it's really easy to
Caption: just keep adding more to it
Caption: this is where i got the device data from
Caption: as well from the previous slides
Caption: so yeah to recap
Caption: [Music]
Caption: best way to do web performance
Caption: monitoring is to do three things you
Caption: need user-centric performance metrics
Caption: you need to capture those performance
Caption: metrics from real-world devices
Caption: and you need to be able to continuously
Caption: observe those so we need to be able to
Caption: see
Caption: the advantage of being able to
Caption: continuously observe is
Caption: we can capture a quick regression we can
Caption: have a pr that gets merged everything
Caption: starts running oh look it's something's
Caption: gone wrong the performance profile has
Caption: changed in the wrong way we can roll
Caption: that back very quickly
Caption: um yeah that's that's all of it that's
Caption: that's the three the three goals we did
Caption: it
Caption: thanks everyone
Caption: that's me if you want to
Caption: if you want to like attack me on twitter
Caption: for uh
Caption: roasting the place where you work so
Caption: that's that's how you do that if you
Caption: want to know
Caption: i've also got all the resources here you
Caption: can find my slides
Caption: using using any of those links there
Caption: i'll share them out
Caption: so all the resources everything i talked
Caption: about there
Caption: here's how to
Caption: learn about all of those metrics as well
Caption: more than just the 10 seconds i gave
Caption: them on stage
Caption: here's some really useful tools so all
Caption: the tools i covered versus some other
Caption: stuff as well
Caption: has anyone got any questions
Caption: rhys
Caption: making me nervous man
Caption: um i just wanted to
Caption: get your opinion so there was um google
Caption: had those kind of
Caption: green to red
Caption: not so good good
Caption: i was kind of surprised
Caption: that the numbers nowadays are still
Caption: quite high i think you said 1.8 seconds
Caption: her first contentful paint
Caption: like i shot it at 1.8 seconds oh my god
Caption: what are we doing like you know what are
Caption: your feelings on that am i being
Caption: ridiculous or is what's good for macklin
Caption: what do you think is good what are you
Caption: aiming for
Caption: i think you might be surprised um like
Caption: if we go back to i'm not gonna go back
Caption: to the leaderboards you guys don't need
Caption: to see that again but if you go back to
Caption: the leaderboards um quite a lot of first
Caption: contentful paint i don't think anyone
Caption: got less than a second um less than a
Caption: second sounds really good that sounds
Caption: like what you'd want but um
Caption: it is actually pretty hard to get to
Caption: that to that score um and i think google
Caption: has said it in such a way that i think
Caption: it accounts for
Caption: uh accounts for that variability so not
Caption: everyone has
Caption: a device that's going to ensure that we
Caption: can get it in 1.8 seconds the majority
Caption: of people have devices that are
Caption: significantly slower than the device you
Caption: and i probably use um it's accounting
Caption: for that it's accounting for people in
Caption: in
Caption: jurisdictions like geo locations like uh
Caption: rural australia or
Caption: um
Caption: parts of india and stuff like that where
Caption: they are going to not actually be able
Caption: to attain that level of performance as
Caption: well
Caption: um one of the 4g providers was 10 times
Caption: faster than the others do you know who
Caption: that was so i can switch my mobile plan
Caption: so the question was one of the one of
Caption: the 4g providers was really fast that
Caption: was actually based on location so um
Caption: and it wasn't perth either so that that
Caption: that
Caption: shot that slide was um
Caption: across wa um you actually tend to find
Caption: you get better performance in some
Caption: rural but not very rural town so i think
Caption: that might have been something like cal
Caption: barry
Caption: they've got a tower there it serves uh
Caption: comparatively less people than it does
Caption: in perth so some perth suburbs mostly
Caption: sort of sit around the middle there and
Caption: then very rural places will have those
Caption: lower
Caption: scores awesome talk man i love the uh
Caption: sponsor comparison
Caption: um
Caption: we also at my company were using the
Caption: google library to send the analytics to
Caption: in our case new relic
Caption: and new relic also
Caption: monitored that through their own
Caption: mechanism and we found that the numbers
Caption: were different
Caption: and i just wondered if you'd come across
Caption: different values for the core web vitals
Caption: with different tooling
Caption: that's really interesting um
Caption: yeah i they they vary a lot and like um
Caption: uh if you just run two
Caption: google lighthouse
Caption: scores back to back you're not going to
Caption: get the same results as well um
Caption: but yeah even if we're kind of looking
Caption: at exactly the same data i'm not sure
Caption: the difference there the one thing i
Caption: could probably say is maybe
Caption: that web vitals library um it has to run
Caption: sort of in javascript space javascript
Caption: runtime whereas um the one that's built
Caption: into google chrome as much as they try
Caption: and keep that the same maybe they can
Caption: kind of detect different things in in
Caption: the browser and they come up with
Caption: different scores i'd imagine they keep
Caption: it as close as they possibly can
Caption: um
Caption: but yeah that's some sort of variability
Caption: in there how how much different was it
Caption: out for you
Caption: it was uh mostly around the cls scores
Caption: so like the new relic one was very
Caption: positive but the google one was a bit it
Caption: felt more realistic so we sort of
Caption: trusted
Caption: the google javascript library more than
Caption: you relics at the time
Caption: yeah okay that's interesting um
Caption: i i don't know how knew i could put that
Caption: together as well i imagine there's a
Caption: guide for how to put it together maybe
Caption: um i know that that web vitals library
Caption: is largely
Caption: something that supports chrome more than
Caption: other browsers maybe new relic went and
Caption: rewrote it themselves and figured out
Caption: how to get it to work in webkit and and
Caption: firefox i can't speculate on that but um
Caption: there could actually be different codes
Caption: sort of detecting that
Caption: thank you so much macklin if everyone
Caption: can just give him another round of
Caption: approvals for that amazing call
Caption: and it's now time for changeover if you
Caption: want to stay here for the next talk on
Caption: project insanity keep your seat
Caption: otherwise head out into the hall and
Caption: find where you want to go next thanks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: this office nerd's nerding what we're
Caption: doing is we're talking to people all
Caption: over the world because we're stuck in
Caption: our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: like
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: first
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol
Caption: she's also been a practice manager
Caption: delivery manager and a regional manager
Caption: for consulting organizations and she
Caption: currently heads up the strategy and
Caption: design team at insight here in perth so
Caption: please welcome her to the stage to talk
Caption: about project insanity
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: hi so i'm giselle thank you for choosing
Caption: to come to my presentation and for all
Caption: of my insight team mates supporting me
Caption: thank you very much i really appreciate
Caption: it
Caption: have you ever walked into a project and
Caption: got that sense of deja vu
Caption: where all the problems you've seen
Caption: before
Caption: many many times before
Caption: we'll picture this you're a project
Caption: manager been asked to go into a new
Caption: project
Caption: you know the cio because you've worked
Caption: with him in a different organization
Caption: before but you've never worked for this
Caption: particular organization so you're a bit
Caption: green in this world
Caption: so in order to help set the scene i've
Caption: invited one of my teammates trent kane
Caption: to play the role of the cio
Caption: hi gizelle how you going i'm great
Caption: thanks trent team we've got my computer
Caption: set up i've got my credentials it's all
Caption: going well i was about to start doing
Caption: some digging for some background
Caption: information could you point me to where
Caption: the business case is please
Caption: um we didn't need to do a business case
Caption: for this project
Caption: it's uh being driven by a need to
Caption: replace some legacy software so we've
Caption: got some legacy replacement funds set
Caption: aside
Caption: okay
Caption: um
Caption: so do we at least have um a budget for
Caption: it that i need to work towards um only
Caption: your budget uh we've got a in-house team
Caption: that'll do everything else you need
Caption: oh well it's good to know that there's a
Caption: team um are they aware the project's
Caption: coming and have they already been
Caption: allocated
Caption: not specifically
Caption: but they're a really good team of uh
Caption: business and technology people they'll
Caption: be able to help you out with whatever
Caption: you need just get in touch with their
Caption: team leads when you need them
Caption: um okay cool now i recall when we spoke
Caption: previously you said you wanted this to
Caption: be an agile project so the it team and
Caption: the business familiar with agile
Caption: not exactly but that's why we have you
Caption: great
Caption: so have we at least got a product owner
Caption: yeah i've got great news we've got a
Caption: product owner called robert he's from
Caption: records and he's an up-and-coming star
Caption: he's what you might call an sme um he
Caption: knows a lot about our business and was
Caption: involved in the last incarnation of this
Caption: project
Caption: it doesn't sound like robert's very
Caption: senior though can he make the decisions
Caption: that needs to be made oh that's fine
Caption: robert will have to work with the
Caption: committee on all decisions
Caption: so we have a committee then yeah we've
Caption: got our standard board and they meet
Caption: monthly we can have an urgent decision
Caption: meeting but no more than once a
Caption: fortnight
Caption: right um
Caption: i've got to say i'm a bit concerned
Caption: about this because you know in an agile
Caption: project we need to be able to make
Caption: decisions almost on the spot
Caption: um but anyway um you mentioned a
Caption: previous incarnation what happened with
Caption: that why didn't it succeed
Caption: well it was a new technology the it team
Caption: didn't know what they were doing it
Caption: dragged on and took forever so we kind
Caption: of cancelled it
Caption: i also don't think the project manager
Caption: was very good
Caption: poor project manager
Caption: luckily we have you this time
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: um all right so i'd like to start
Caption: talking to the business if i can because
Caption: this this project's actually going to
Caption: impact a lot of people so the sooner i
Caption: can start talking to them better so can
Caption: you tell me who i should talk to
Caption: there's no need to talk to the business
Caption: the it team know exactly what we need
Caption: this is a like for like replacement of
Caption: our current system so we have all the
Caption: requirements laid out
Caption: oh dear this is going to be good
Caption: um i really think we need to talk to the
Caption: business because you know there's going
Caption: to be a huge change impact here um do we
Caption: at least have an internal change
Caption: management team that i can leverage
Caption: we've got a corporate comms team and
Caption: they can manage most of that and for
Caption: anything else i'm sure you can handle it
Caption: anyway i've got a meeting to run too
Caption: nice
Caption: thanks trent
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: p.s trent would never say any of those
Caption: things he actually he actually heads up
Caption: our design crew so you know business
Caption: engagement user experience all those
Caption: things are pretty important
Caption: so
Caption: is this project destined to become
Caption: project insanity
Caption: if it could go wrong it will go wrong in
Caption: this there is so many things that are
Caption: big red flags
Caption: now in fairness it's unlikely that
Caption: you're going to walk into a project
Caption: which has all of them but i'm sure every
Caption: single one of us in this room has
Caption: experienced many of those particular
Caption: scenarios before
Caption: so the reality is though there's a few
Caption: themes that come out
Caption: when you actually look at it so whilst
Caption: there was a lot of things that we raised
Caption: there there were some key themes that we
Caption: talked about
Caption: so the first one's actually around
Caption: funding so
Caption: there's no business case for this it's
Caption: part of the legacy replacement fund
Caption: so what we've got money to actually
Caption: change a system but we've got no money
Caption: for anything else
Caption: nothing else on me i'm the project
Caption: manager i'm i'm funded
Caption: you know but what about the rest of the
Caption: team
Caption: there's no funding for additional
Caption: resources we're going to need some
Caption: change management on this we're
Caption: replacing a legacy system with something
Caption: new how can we manage without some
Caption: change management it is going to impact
Caption: the business
Caption: and there's no budget allocated for the
Caption: internal resources either so if you
Caption: think about it we're going to use the
Caption: bau resources fantastic
Caption: but they've got a day job
Caption: and given that they have a day job
Caption: somebody's still got to do it that job
Caption: doesn't go away so if we want to use
Caption: those people then they're going to need
Caption: to be back filled so we need some money
Caption: for it
Caption: so
Caption: but money budget in this particular
Caption: scenario the next one's resourcing so
Caption: resourcing generally is a big issue on
Caption: this one we've got a product owner good
Caption: news
Caption: he doesn't really he's not a product
Caption: owner he's a great guy clearly he knows
Caption: stuff he's only allocated 50 of the time
Caption: but he can't make any decisions
Caption: so how good a product owner is he going
Caption: to be
Caption: the resources don't even know this is
Caption: coming yet
Caption: so yeah we're going to use the i.t team
Caption: i've just got to go talk to their
Caption: managers and get them on board that's
Caption: going to be easy
Caption: yeah right
Caption: and they're only part-time
Caption: when you have resources who are only
Caption: part-time dedicated to a project
Caption: it's always a sign of potential issue
Caption: and the reason i say that is because if
Caption: they've got a bau responsibility on one
Caption: side of the fence and they've got a
Caption: project responsibility on another side
Caption: of the fence
Caption: when they are trying when there's a fire
Caption: in bau land guess what takes priority
Caption: every time they will go back to their
Caption: bau work and your project will suffer
Caption: so the next theme is around decision
Caption: making we've got a committee yay
Caption: once a month we can get a decision
Caption: they want this to be agile hello this is
Caption: not going to happen right
Caption: once a month
Caption: board decision
Caption: and what's worse we all know that with
Caption: committees invariably they don't make a
Caption: decision straight away
Caption: so it might be two months before you can
Caption: even get a decision all three even worse
Caption: and like i said before the product owner
Caption: is just not
Caption: senior enough to make decisions he's not
Caption: a decision maker he's not somebody that
Caption: the organization will respect and agree
Caption: to his decisions there needs to be
Caption: somebody
Caption: at a very senior level who other people
Caption: will
Caption: adhere to the decisions that they made
Caption: business engagement
Caption: no need to engage the business i i.t
Caption: know what they want
Caption: gotta love it how many times have you
Caption: heard that the i.t team know exactly
Caption: what the business wants
Caption: how can they
Caption: sure they may know some of the things
Caption: that are wrong with the existing systems
Caption: and they know some of the gripes that
Caption: come out of the business but they don't
Caption: know everybody's job and all the things
Caption: that they do in their day-to-day job
Caption: they don't know the things that drive
Caption: those people insane
Caption: because of what they have to do with the
Caption: systems they're doing they don't know
Caption: the processes
Caption: they do not know what the requirements
Caption: are
Caption: no ux
Caption: gotta love this one
Caption: as trent actually said recently there's
Caption: no such thing as no ux
Caption: if you've got people involved and a
Caption: system there is a user experience
Caption: if you don't design for it it will be a
Caption: bad experience you need to design for it
Caption: to make sure that it's a good user
Caption: experience
Caption: no change management yay we've got a
Caption: comms team
Caption: so good they can send out some emails
Caption: and they can put something up on their
Caption: internet that's going to be really cool
Caption: but that's not change management
Caption: change management involves bringing
Caption: people along the journey so that when
Caption: they get to the end
Caption: they embrace whatever it is whatever
Caption: technology it is that you're trying to
Caption: put in
Caption: like i said corporate comms are not
Caption: change managers
Caption: and they've got a very busy workload
Caption: anyway so they're not going to be able
Caption: to do very much
Caption: and then the final bit
Caption: agile they've got no idea what agile is
Caption: this is going to be an agile project yay
Caption: if you're going to try and run an agile
Caption: project for an organization that's never
Caption: done agile before you're going to spend
Caption: an awful lot of time in coaching and
Caption: training just to bring them along that
Caption: journey which is going to eat into the
Caption: time for the project
Caption: so in this particular case the
Caption: organization is very immature they don't
Caption: know what they're letting themselves in
Caption: for they don't even know what they've
Caption: asked for and out of the box how many
Caption: times have you heard this it's out of
Caption: the box
Caption: no because customization it's just
Caption: configuration and that's why we don't
Caption: need to talk to the users hello have you
Caption: ever seen a legacy system replaced by
Caption: something off the shelf that's exactly
Caption: the same that follows exactly the same
Caption: processes as the previous one
Caption: and why would you do that anyway
Caption: because the reason for changing is to
Caption: improve things
Caption: so either you're going to have to do a
Caption: lot of change management around
Caption: processes and organizations and how
Caption: people work or you're going to have to
Caption: customize the heck out of this piece of
Caption: software in order to make it feel like
Caption: the one they had before
Caption: and it's always configuration and how do
Caption: you configure it unless you talk to the
Caption: business
Caption: you don't know what to configure it with
Caption: so
Caption: lots and lots of red flags in here
Caption: it's no wonder the last one failed if
Caption: they followed the same premise last time
Caption: it was never going to succeed
Caption: so what can we do about it
Caption: as the project manager on this there are
Caption: a number of things that i can do
Caption: um whoa when my pictures have all gone
Caption: there we go there are a number of things
Caption: that i can do
Caption: the first one
Caption: is actually to do
Caption: to define what success is
Caption: right at the moment success is replace
Caption: xyz legacy system with project insanity
Caption: and all will be well
Caption: replacement of a system is not a
Caption: definition of success
Caption: for success to happen it's got to be
Caption: measurable
Caption: so this is the success maybe
Caption: people are now more efficient
Caption: that the organization makes more money
Caption: that we can do more with less
Caption: whatever it is but it has to be
Caption: measurable
Caption: replacing a legacy system with something
Caption: new is not a definition of success
Caption: and in this scenario sure you can go and
Caption: create something new but it won't work
Caption: it won't be successful
Caption: because the people aren't involved
Caption: because the organization doesn't know
Caption: what they're getting into
Caption: next thing project management 101 have a
Caption: plan
Caption: we all know the old adage plan
Caption: failed to plan and you plan to fail
Caption: in this scenario that is so true
Caption: the plan will need to be really really
Caption: robust
Caption: and the schedule needs to encompass
Caption: everything that you know needs to happen
Caption: not just what they think needs to happen
Caption: but what you know needs to happen
Caption: and then
Caption: once you've done that and this is the
Caption: most critical step
Caption: is to actually run a risk workshop with
Caption: all the key stakeholders
Caption: you need to get them in a room
Caption: and help them to identify all the risks
Caption: and you need to be very very
Caption: granular so we can't have a risk that
Caption: says resources aren't available
Caption: the risk has to be we can't get the
Caption: resources from finance when we need them
Caption: to be able to do whatever it is or the
Caption: bau it resources get pulled off onto bau
Caption: activities and off the project all of
Caption: those are different risks and you need a
Caption: different risk for every single resource
Caption: issue
Caption: and the reason you need a different risk
Caption: is is that you then need to get an owner
Caption: for all of those risks so the owner for
Caption: the one about the finance people would
Caption: be the finance manager the owner for the
Caption: one about the it people would be the it
Caption: manager
Caption: and then
Caption: more important still they have to take
Caption: some action to make sure that it is
Caption: mitigated so define the risks identify
Caption: the mitigation and the owner and then
Caption: make it happen
Caption: and then you can come up with a budget
Caption: because we've just doubled the cost of
Caption: this project
Caption: with the schedule that i would have come
Caption: up with in this particular scenario at
Caption: least
Caption: in order to make it work agree the
Caption: budget if you can't get agreement on the
Caption: budget which includes backfilling your
Caption: bau resources or whatever it is
Caption: great time to walk away
Caption: because it won't succeed it will go over
Caption: budget and then everyone will be
Caption: screaming at you
Caption: and and bear in mind i'm taking this
Caption: from the perspective of a project
Caption: manager but even as a team member on the
Caption: team you can help identify those risks
Caption: and help to work to mitigate those risks
Caption: and to
Caption: you know take ownership of some of those
Caption: risks so it's not just the project
Caption: manager and the project manager cannot
Caption: own the risks
Caption: they must be owned by someone who could
Caption: do something about it so i've seen
Caption: project risk schedules this big the
Caption: owner of all of them is the project
Caption: manager still won't work
Caption: and there's a whole load of others which
Caption: i don't really have time to do deal with
Caption: but
Caption: you know agree ways of working engage
Caption: the business you got to talk to them
Caption: demonstrate bad ux and get the people
Caption: who who are on side to see it
Caption: so i'll leave you with two things the
Caption: first is is that i.t projects
Caption: rarely fail
Caption: because of the technology
Caption: i.t projects generally fail because of
Caption: all of the things around it
Caption: it's the people and process
Caption: and money
Caption: aspects that make it fail so we're
Caption: talking people we're talking the
Caption: resourcing we're talking the business
Caption: engagement money's obvious the funding
Caption: one and the process how decisions are
Caption: made how you're going to work on the
Caption: project if you don't get all of those
Caption: things right
Caption: that's what will cause the project to
Caption: fail not the lack of the technology to
Caption: do its job
Caption: because we've got some really really
Caption: clever technical folk out here who can
Caption: make it work and they'll always overcome
Caption: those challenges
Caption: and at the end of the day the
Caption: stakeholders need to acknowledge
Caption: that the is there are risks
Caption: they need to accept ownership for those
Caption: risks
Caption: and then they need to action those risks
Caption: and if you can get them to do all that
Caption: you've got the best possible chance of
Caption: success in this scenario you still might
Caption: not you still might fail but it'll give
Caption: you the best possible chance of success
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you so much for that amazing talk
Caption: um i know that i've definitely learned a
Caption: few things i'll be on the lookout in the
Caption: next project that i'm joining in
Caption: hopefully not quite as many red flags
Caption: um so we're ready for the change of the
Caption: sessions um i've been told that we are
Caption: having a few issues with our website so
Caption: i'll just read out which of the talks
Caption: are on over the next session and which
Caption: room they're in
Caption: and hopefully you can catch out which
Caption: one it is the issue is intermittent
Caption: so we have ben lowry talking about
Caption: offline first not on offline mode and
Caption: that's in the quaker room or in the
Caption: theater
Caption: we've also got ming johansen talking
Caption: about how to be productive when working
Caption: remote
Caption: in the quandong room
Caption: and we have josh armitage talking about
Caption: serverless testing in the yawn or blob
Caption: tale
Caption: we've got damien brady with end to end
Caption: devops with github in the manganch or
Caption: banksia room
Caption: melissa horton talking about leadership
Caption: through self-awareness in
Caption: yibi or black cockatoo
Caption: we've got troy garwin talking about the
Caption: limits of my programming language mean
Caption: the limits of my world and that's in
Caption: mari or red gum
Caption: aaron powell talking about unleashing
Caption: the power of vs code in
Caption: jagala nagala which is in the gala room
Caption: and ashley aitken talking about i'm a
Caption: computer so are you in the billiard or
Caption: river room which is just through there
Caption: and we've also got anton ball in this
Caption: room talking about superhero layouts
Caption: so thank you guys so much another round
Caption: of applause please for giselle for that
Caption: amazing talk
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: good
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um okay you can you
Caption: can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're sucking up
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh
Caption: the app is almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: pleasure to introduce our next speaker
Caption: anton ball
Caption: he's talking to us today about superhero
Caption: layouts so i hope we get a few superhero
Caption: poses from him
Caption: he is a front end developer speaker and
Caption: community organizer including here at
Caption: ddd perth he's passionate about clean
Caption: and structured code
Caption: web standards accessibility and
Caption: optimization
Caption: and anton prides himself on delivering
Caption: robust high quality and beautiful
Caption: solutions
Caption: anton co organizes offenders front and
Caption: developer meetups and as i said ddd
Caption: perth he's also volunteered as a mentor
Caption: introducing us
Caption: into this wonderful world that is coding
Caption: take it away anton cool
Caption: so
Caption: thanks everyone for coming along i've
Caption: got the uh
Caption: sponsor slides up there so that's good
Caption: that they
Caption: help us to have this uh event for
Caption: a pretty great price really
Caption: so i'm going to be talking about
Caption: superhero layouts uh
Caption: comics are said to have passed through
Caption: four ages with each of the ages known to
Caption: have something distinctive about it
Caption: in the golden age we were first
Caption: introduced to the superhero archetype
Caption: this was around about 1938 or so
Caption: this was our introduction to characters
Caption: like superman wonder woman and batman
Caption: during the silver age the world is
Caption: recovering from a world war and readers
Caption: had matured during that time so to meet
Caption: that maturity the stories were focused
Caption: on horror crime and romance more than
Caption: what they were before
Caption: this sort of helped the industry to
Caption: survive through what was a difficult
Caption: period
Caption: after the silver age many of those
Caption: heroic story lines that the writers
Caption: could think of
Caption: were used so they decided instead the
Caption: fruit of bronze age to tackle the social
Caption: issues of the day this would include
Caption: bigotry racism and substance abuse
Caption: and the modern age is a time of redesign
Caption: growth and some disruption by the web
Caption: anyone can publish now bringing
Caption: more unique stories and making comics
Caption: more accessible than to audiences than
Caption: ever thought possible
Caption: no longer was it about a couple of those
Caption: major players that were creating or
Caption: publishing comics
Caption: and so what makes comics an absorbing
Caption: storytelling medium is that along with
Caption: great characters stories and art styles
Caption: is the impact that the layout can have
Caption: on that story
Caption: and we're going to explore each of the
Caption: ages of comics and how it relates to web
Caption: layout and how css grid combined with
Caption: some other css techniques
Caption: can be used to recreate these layouts
Caption: and
Caption: as you're looking at these they're
Caption: obviously very comic book focused but
Caption: think about how you can reimagine the
Caption: techniques that i'm talking about here
Caption: for the use in your layouts and projects
Caption: that you're working on
Caption: and i'm not going to dive too much into
Caption: responsiveness i think there's a lot of
Caption: great articles that cover that with grid
Caption: already
Caption: but it is possible to do so and there's
Caption: a short part here where i will
Caption: cover it so
Caption: those comic book ages that i went
Caption: through spanned about 70 years and
Caption: 70 years is a fairly long time to be
Caption: able to evolve a storytelling medium
Caption: by comparison our industry the web is
Caption: still relatively young html is about 29
Caption: years old and css is 25 and that makes
Caption: me older than both of them unfortunately
Caption: not combined but that's still okay
Caption: so the web is after all young and so if
Caption: anyone else is older than them so are we
Caption: but the point i'm getting at to here is
Caption: in a relatively short period of time
Caption: layout on the web progressed through
Caption: many ages of its own we started off with
Caption: just html this was the text links basic
Caption: elements
Caption: we sort of co-opted tables to do what
Caption: they weren't really meant to do and we
Caption: started using them for layouts
Caption: the first of our comic book crossovers
Caption: flash came along gave us very dynamic
Caption: layouts but it had its own problems and
Caption: we've been going through absolute float
Caption: responsive and i think we're kind of
Caption: heading into the intrinsic era which is
Caption: a term that i've seen jen simmons coin
Caption: it's talking more about letting the
Caption: devices define the layout a bit more we
Caption: have foldable phones we have fridges
Caption: all sorts of things
Caption: so all that in 29 short years less than
Caption: half of that of our friends in the comic
Caption: industry so it can be really tempting at
Caption: times to give leia on the web a hard
Caption: time but
Caption: given the relatively young age that our
Caption: industry is i think it's amazing how far
Caption: we've progressed and we can certainly
Caption: appreciate what we have now when you
Caption: consider where it is that we've come
Caption: from
Caption: so
Caption: is the current age of the web going to
Caption: be considered the web's modern age and
Caption: with css grid i think that might just be
Caption: the case
Caption: so before i jump too much into code this
Caption: is me anton ball
Caption: i'm local here to perth
Caption: and i've always kind of brought my
Caption: daughter along to these events so you
Caption: might see me rocking around with her a
Caption: little bit more later
Caption: and as you know i'm older than html and
Caption: css
Caption: i'm a full stack team lead at doest we
Caption: make todoist and twist applications you
Caption: can find me on twitter at antonjv if you
Caption: want to
Caption: and perhaps this is extra information at
Caption: this point but i quite enjoy comics
Caption: so
Caption: undoubtedly one of the most important
Caption: comics in history is action comics
Caption: number one this was as i said released
Caption: around 1938
Caption: and what makes it an important comic in
Caption: the history of all comics is it's the
Caption: introduction of superman and just so
Caption: we're all clear that's him holding the
Caption: car up there now superman has changed a
Caption: lot through the years but this is where
Caption: they started
Caption: the layout throughout the comics and
Caption: others even in the golden and silver age
Caption: consisted primarily of rows of squares
Caption: and rectangles if we look at a few of
Caption: the pages from the comic we can see that
Caption: pattern in use we'll have a couple of
Caption: squares a long larger rectangle with the
Caption: uh in it but what we are focused on is
Caption: layout so i'm going to strip out the
Caption: imagery and see what we are left with
Caption: the pattern was one to three panels per
Caption: row staggered throughout the page with a
Caption: somewhat consistent gap it was printed
Caption: so you know somewhat consistent
Caption: in terms of css grid it's a nice
Caption: starting off point uh we
Caption: might think that we can do great
Caption: template rows and sort of repeat three
Caption: times over one fraction but
Caption: we need to go a little bit further if we
Caption: want to achieve the staggering that we
Caption: can hopefully see here can you actually
Caption: see the staggering
Caption: it's can you see the gray squares
Caption: i suspect not
Caption: um
Caption: all right
Caption: so the way i calculated the columns is
Caption: to measure the smallest panel on the
Caption: layout and divide that by the width of
Caption: the comet so the smallest panel would be
Caption: between two gaps there that you can see
Caption: we aren't using that size but it gives
Caption: us the basis with which to work from so
Caption: between two panels there's there don't
Caption: worry more color comes in later
Caption: so when we divide the page width which
Caption: is 576
Caption: by the 36 which is the smallest panel we
Caption: could possibly do that gives us the
Caption: total number of columns we would want to
Caption: recreate this layout
Caption: importantly it's the same aspect ratio
Caption: as the printed version
Caption: so turning that into grid we have
Caption: display grid grid template columns
Caption: repeat 16 times over one fraction
Caption: and the grid gap we can be super
Caption: consistent now because we're in the web
Caption: so
Caption: we don't need grid template roads in
Caption: this example because we can rely on the
Caption: implicit grid to handle that for us
Caption: and so what do i mean by the implicit
Caption: grid
Caption: if we were to fill up all of the
Caption: contents filling that first defined grid
Caption: grid will automatically add a new track
Caption: to the row underneath which will fill up
Caption: with those columns as well and by
Caption: default the implicit grid tracks are
Caption: automatically sized
Caption: we can start controlling that if we want
Caption: to with grid order rows or grid auto
Caption: columns
Caption: but for the purposes of our demo we're
Caption: happy for the grid to just keep
Caption: repeating over as we use it
Caption: and each panel can then span the number
Caption: of columns required there so panel one
Caption: spans across six panel two spans across
Caption: five and we start to get the layout of
Caption: our grid with
Caption: the staggering so there we go we've
Caption: created a comic layout with only a few
Caption: lines of css
Caption: and the staggering is a nice touch to
Caption: avoid being too symmetrical in layout we
Caption: never want it being all the same
Caption: but it's while it's not much code for a
Caption: lot of possibilities we aren't really
Caption: feeling like superheroes just yet
Caption: so the layout in action comic one didn't
Caption: play a huge role in the story itself so
Caption: it's it's more used as a container and
Caption: that was about it
Caption: so let's instead jump forward to the
Caption: bronze age which brings us with a change
Caption: in how layout did become a part of the
Caption: story
Caption: spider-man 1-2-1 was released around
Caption: 1973 and considered a pivotal point in
Caption: this character's
Caption: sort of story arc and their history
Caption: now i hope it's not a spoiler for
Caption: something from 1973 but this is the
Caption: death of gwen stacy which if you've seen
Caption: any of the movies lately you're probably
Caption: familiar with it we can talk about it
Caption: later
Caption: so what's great about this story along
Caption: with the moment artwork and everything
Caption: involved is the way that the layout
Caption: became an integral part of its telling
Caption: the height of the bridge in the fall is
Caption: shown beautifully through those spanning
Caption: panels
Caption: you wouldn't get that sense of height
Caption: or danger from the grid if it was like
Caption: the previous example all running along
Caption: several rows
Caption: so even though it's a great moment in
Caption: there let's again strip out the artwork
Caption: and see the layout in use
Caption: so the big difference is the panel
Caption: spanning multiple rows this is one of
Caption: the areas where grid has given us a
Caption: sense of a modern layer we're no longer
Caption: are we constrained to a single axis and
Caption: the way that i determine the panels was
Caption: done as the same in the previous one
Caption: this time though we have 23
Caption: so we're still able to rely on implicit
Caption: grid even though we're spanning multiple
Caption: rows now
Caption: because grid will allow us to do that
Caption: so we add in panel one we span across
Caption: nine like we did before but now we can
Caption: span down three rows and grid will
Caption: handle that panel two will span across
Caption: seven panel three uh will be whatever
Caption: the rest of 23 minus nine and seven is
Caption: and then panel four will just slide into
Caption: place there grid gives us a lot of
Caption: things for free which is nice
Caption: and we were able to now cover a great
Caption: many of the layouts during and up to the
Caption: bronze age
Caption: so next up in the journey through the
Caption: ages is watchmen which famous for many
Caption: reasons like the movie
Caption: but it kicked off the modern age of
Caption: comics now watchmen adhered to a strict
Caption: nine panel grid throughout its run which
Caption: means what we've created so far would
Caption: essentially cover this whole comic book
Caption: or this series
Caption: so there's hundreds of possibilities
Caption: with a nine panel grid which is not me
Caption: recommending everyone go out and do that
Caption: it just means that it's very powerful
Caption: but there was a panel from watchman that
Caption: i wanted to recreate it did something
Caption: just a little bit outside the box with
Caption: grid
Caption: now the panel in the middle there it's
Caption: there's a lot going on with the speech
Caption: bubbles but the artwork you can see is
Caption: the same image running across the three
Caption: panels it's not just constrained into
Caption: one anymore
Caption: now we could split the image into three
Caption: if we wanted to it would make it quite
Caption: easy
Caption: but i think it's better if we can
Caption: recreate the effect while we maintain
Caption: the image
Caption: it'll give us some flexibility so if we
Caption: want to swap the image out later we're
Caption: only going to have to do the one and not
Caption: remember all the various steps and
Caption: cutting them up into three
Caption: or if we want to
Caption: work with some responsiveness which
Caption: we'll see in this one
Caption: so the setup here is similar to what we
Caption: had before where i'm aiming to have the
Caption: image remain intact while we add the gap
Caption: in there
Caption: so panel 3 which is in the middle we are
Caption: going to wrap that in another grid so we
Caption: have our main grid laid out like we have
Caption: before and panel 3 has a grid in there
Caption: as well and it's spanning multiple
Caption: columns so we have room enough to place
Caption: the gap
Caption: now only the direct children of a
Caption: container can become grid items but with
Caption: subgrid we're able to inherit the rows
Caption: or columns from the parent element
Caption: now that's what happens here when we add
Caption: sub grid onto
Caption: the overlap area
Caption: so we'll look at it without the image to
Caption: try and better understand what's
Caption: happening overlap is pulling in the rows
Caption: from the main comic itself
Caption: with that sub grid
Caption: but we don't if the comics sorry if the
Caption: columns in the main comic one where to
Caption: change if we would add more or change it
Caption: to be a different ratio then the sub
Caption: panel or overlapper would inherit that
Caption: so we're getting that just for free
Caption: but we don't have to inherit the whole
Caption: grid in this case we can set our own
Caption: rows in there as well so we can only
Caption: inherit what we want and leave the rest
Caption: out now why that might be useful is if
Caption: we were to say add the speech bubbles in
Caption: we're going to have a better chance of
Caption: positioning them on the page
Caption: so putting the graphics back it's time
Caption: to achieve the gap in there
Caption: we do this with a suitor element we add
Caption: that to the overlap container
Caption: in there we give it the same
Caption: graphic visuals as the outline so we
Caption: give it the same grid gap and the same
Caption: coloring i've just used a custom
Caption: property there just to kind of give an
Caption: example of how that could be easier
Caption: and put it into place
Caption: and so there we go that's ticked off our
Caption: goal of maintaining the image while
Caption: simulating a grid gap
Caption: now if we wanted say for mobile if for a
Caption: little bit of responsiveness we could
Caption: drop that gap off and just have the
Caption: whole image there if we were thinking
Caption: outside of just comics here
Caption: so subgrid is a great next step for grit
Caption: anytime you've struggled to align items
Caption: without setting the height across
Caption: multiple panels
Caption: and i'm sure if you've ever done front
Caption: end you've probably had those three
Caption: panels and there'll be some headings on
Caption: the top and some content in the middle
Caption: and some of them will have like only a
Caption: tiny bit of text and then the other
Caption: one's like a short novel and they all
Caption: get stretched out so with subgrid we'll
Caption: start to be able to inherit across rows
Caption: or across columns and keep them
Caption: consistent
Caption: this is an example from the todoist
Caption: website where we run into this so i've
Caption: used the german language here because
Caption: they're always good for like long words
Caption: that you can test with these areas so if
Caption: we set height we run the risk of cutting
Caption: the text off or having that overlap if
Caption: we set a minimum height well then we
Caption: have the weird sort of thing where now
Caption: the buttons aren't lining up and if you
Caption: have the designs they typically will
Caption: line up
Caption: so we're running we have that problem so
Caption: grid and sub grid are going to have us
Caption: covered if the middle content was to
Caption: grow the others will grow in all three
Caption: panels it'll be very handy and the
Caption: advantage over the flat grid setup is we
Caption: get the flexibility of the expanding
Caption: rows while we get to maintain the
Caption: semantic relationship of each of the
Caption: elements each one can be in its own
Caption: semantic div or whatever it may be
Caption: and we're covered
Caption: but where's browser support at with some
Caption: grid
Caption: not not great
Caption: we're still a little bit in experimental
Caption: territory here and and that's okay you
Caption: can still sometimes use it the only
Caption: browser with subgrid sort of fully
Caption: implemented is firefox as in released
Caption: and i actually did it all the way back
Caption: in 2019 the day after i gave this talk
Caption: once they did it now safari recently
Caption: enabled subgrid in the technical preview
Caption: that's why i said firefox is the only
Caption: one but it's it's in there which means
Caption: by the next versions of safari we'll
Caption: start to see some grid
Caption: but there is hope
Caption: in all of this some grid has been
Caption: included in interop 2022
Caption: which is a combined effort by browser
Caption: vendors and people that also write code
Caption: for supporting web standards to close a
Caption: gap in some of these css features
Caption: so
Caption: they are all going to basically work
Caption: towards having subgrid implemented and
Caption: passing the same test so that it is
Caption: displayed correctly across all of the
Caption: browsers
Caption: before that though
Caption: and before subgrid is more widely
Caption: available we can recreate this effect
Caption: with display content so we've added that
Caption: to overlap and essentially what it does
Caption: is gets rid of that container in there
Caption: and lifts the items up into the parent
Caption: grid which is our comic
Caption: we do lose a semantic meaning though
Caption: which is why i think subgrid is going to
Caption: be a better option for us if we had some
Caption: very specific semantic meaning by adding
Caption: the display contents it's gone
Caption: so that can be a bit of a problem
Caption: now it's the next evolution during the
Caption: modern age of comics where layout
Caption: really gets creative and interesting
Caption: we're revisiting the world of spider-man
Caption: here we'll do that a few times because
Caption: he's a bit of a favorite of mine
Caption: but we started to see a new trend in
Caption: this age of comics
Caption: this modern age brought with it layering
Caption: panels to achieve a flow and depth that
Caption: we hadn't previously seen artists were
Caption: able to focus in and provide little
Caption: detail elements without taking up all
Caption: the space that others had
Caption: now layering's certainly not new to the
Caption: web but grid enables us to layer in much
Caption: easier and predictable ways than with a
Caption: previous option so let's take a look at
Caption: some of the code
Caption: we have display grid we have grid
Caption: template columns and then we have all
Caption: these numbers
Caption: and it's like wow yeah that's so much
Caption: easier than what it was before
Caption: but here's how i figured it out and if
Caption: you have the artwork
Caption: that can be useful which we often do
Caption: with from the the friends in design or
Caption: if you design yourself
Caption: and we'll focus on the rows so the
Caption: number of rows that we have is nine we
Caption: have nine we have that we want to place
Caption: out
Caption: in here now this is starting to look
Caption: like a similar trend
Caption: if we divide the height by the number of
Caption: rows we get
Caption: a base for one fraction unit so we can
Caption: do this with one of the panels as well
Caption: we can use that as one fraction
Caption: but this is the way that i kind of went
Caption: for it
Caption: so next we divide the height of an
Caption: individual row by that base fraction
Caption: so 291 is the row we want 109 is the
Caption: base unit that we're using and that
Caption: gives us 2.6 fraction units
Caption: so what what are these fraction units
Caption: and why we do we keep using them in grid
Caption: they
Caption: give us a bit more flexibility when we
Caption: need to make everything responsive and
Caption: maintain the aspect ratio and also if
Caption: you can't really use percentages because
Caption: we have the gap value in grid as well
Caption: and if you use percentages with gaps
Caption: things will start to get weird and over
Caption: overlap
Caption: but if we use the fractions it's going
Caption: to stick within those bounds and the
Caption: gaps will also help to stick it in there
Caption: or they will they will work together
Caption: with gap rather than against it
Caption: and we repeat that same process to
Caption: determine the columns
Caption: so there we go that's how we got to all
Caption: those numbers
Caption: now we can then layer our panels over
Caption: the top where needed using grid row and
Caption: grid column values so our panel 3 which
Caption: has the young lady in it we have grid
Caption: row four to seven and grid column five
Caption: span
Caption: one and z index just to bring it up onto
Caption: the top
Caption: now panel four we have grid row five
Caption: through to nine so we're saying from 5 2
Caption: 9 but interestingly we have grid column
Caption: 2 to negative 2.
Caption: so
Caption: where does this negative 2 come from in
Caption: here the grid lines each of the lines in
Caption: a grid are numbered 1 through to n in
Caption: our case that's eight the total number
Caption: of
Caption: lines that we have
Caption: so the starting line for panel four is
Caption: two we want it a little bit in
Caption: but those lines are also numbered in
Caption: reverse so from what would be our
Caption: typical reading order from the
Caption: right is negative one through to
Caption: negative n or eight
Caption: so if we wanna
Caption: finish up two lines in we can use
Caption: negative two
Caption: the benefit of that is when inevitably
Caption: our design changes later on if more
Caption: lines are to be added into the middle we
Caption: don't have to update everywhere that we
Caption: do it if we said span to the distance we
Caption: want and then we add something new well
Caption: then now we have to go and update
Caption: everything so as long as we're not
Caption: changing that too much it will adjust
Caption: with the grid it can be pretty handy
Caption: and most of the browser dev tools will
Caption: show you these numbers in this case it's
Caption: firefox but you can inspect the element
Caption: and typically you can turn on line
Caption: numbers line names and other properties
Caption: like that
Caption: so the modern age have made prolific use
Caption: of this layering this is another
Caption: example of hawkeye
Caption: and it can be a great way to finally
Caption: break out of the boxes that have
Caption: contained us in design and layout for so
Caption: many years here's the web recreation on
Caption: the other side that i've done
Caption: and we're not using gap here we're just
Caption: adding some borders so that we can
Caption: because grid can't do sort of funky gaps
Caption: like that but we can overlay each of
Caption: them on there and then start to add some
Caption: borders and create some real interesting
Caption: depth into some of our designs
Caption: but
Caption: with great power comes great
Caption: responsibility
Caption: to keep with the theme
Caption: of what i'm doing
Caption: layering is an exciting addition to our
Caption: layout toolboxes but we do have to
Caption: consider more than just the layout it
Caption: opens up to us there's an inherent
Caption: danger here when you can just position
Caption: something anywhere on the page
Caption: if the source order isn't created
Caption: in a way that makes sense you can
Caption: negatively impact the accessibility of
Caption: your project
Caption: so as an example if we decided that the
Caption: panel 4 was better up the top we can
Caption: just do that we can move it with grid
Caption: but solely changing the visual layout is
Caption: not going to tell the browser
Caption: that the source order has changed so a
Caption: screen reader might come in and start to
Caption: go through that information by going the
Caption: first sort of few images to the girl to
Caption: the
Caption: field whereas we've now changed the
Caption: visual order to field and then the other
Caption: thing is going down so that's something
Caption: that we need to be careful of
Caption: to avoid falling into this trap there's
Caption: a few things that we can do we can look
Caption: at the structure of our document first
Caption: and make sure that we're layering it out
Caption: in html order correctly
Caption: we can then create the grid that
Caption: supports that and then like any hero be
Caption: vigilant and maintain that order when
Caption: you are working on these
Caption: a really good place to start reading
Caption: into grid accessibility is mdm's layout
Caption: and accessibility
Caption: guide that they have on the article
Caption: on the website sorry
Caption: so a common criticism of web design and
Caption: layout is that everything is within a
Caption: box you may have heard it sort of the
Caption: reference to bootstrap layouts or maybe
Caption: a little bit of those libraries that
Caption: have helped us work fast
Caption: but
Caption: have reduced some of the creativity that
Caption: we're able to get from these frameworks
Caption: and so far looking at a lot of these
Caption: comics we have some layering but
Caption: everything is still a box
Caption: now for comics boxy layout started to
Caption: change during the modern age of comics
Caption: the characters broke out of their boxes
Caption: and the storytelling once again evolved
Caption: with them
Caption: now this is a nice example from phoenix
Caption: and jean grey
Caption: showing how different shapes can enhance
Caption: the storytelling and our recreated
Caption: example alongside it so that is running
Caption: and it is of a valid website
Caption: so fundamentally everything within a
Caption: grid is still going to be a box we can't
Caption: do random shapes like this
Caption: but we can combine our boxes with some
Caption: new techniques and get a bit creative
Caption: and give the illusion of almost any
Caption: shape that we like
Caption: so there's a little bit of boilerplate
Caption: in this we're setting up our comic to
Caption: contain everything we've got position
Caption: relative because we're going to do some
Caption: absolute positioning and floating and
Caption: things are going to get weird so we've
Caption: got overflow hidden on there as well to
Caption: make sure nothing escapes
Caption: we want it to break out of the box but
Caption: not too far
Caption: i'm gonna keep it in there
Caption: now the panels grids has a column for
Caption: each of our five panels and they're just
Caption: regular panels going along like we've
Caption: seen before
Caption: but we can only see a few of the images
Caption: and that's because we're needing to
Caption: overlap everything because we're going
Caption: to be cutting away some of the image we
Caption: need the other ones sitting underneath
Caption: we can't have each one in its own cell
Caption: because if we go away and sort of cut
Caption: away the image the background is going
Caption: to show through where we want the image
Caption: now hopefully to help visualize this is
Caption: the layering that we're working with in
Caption: our grid
Caption: in there
Caption: so our panel container is then rotated
Caption: and using absolute position sort of
Caption: positioned along the bottom whereabouts
Caption: we want it and we've rotated it a little
Caption: bit and just sort of shimming it down
Caption: about where we want look the details
Caption: aren't super important we've put it down
Caption: there
Caption: so clip path is what's going to enable
Caption: these shapes that we've wanted
Caption: when you add a clip path rule in this
Caption: case a polygon we have an x y value for
Caption: each of those things and it makes its
Caption: way around the shape and that gives us
Caption: the image now we can apply a clip path
Caption: to each of our images and then we've
Caption: most of the way there with what we were
Caption: doing
Caption: now
Caption: again we've got like all these random
Caption: numbers
Caption: on there and you're probably thinking
Caption: this still doesn't look easier
Caption: but firefox has given us some great
Caption: tools here the dev tools are really
Caption: going to come in handy when you start
Caption: doing some things like this
Caption: if you select the icon in there
Caption: you can start to move the nodes around
Caption: yourself
Caption: and you can double click to add a new
Caption: node and start to drag that and you'll
Caption: see the values are updating in the dev
Caption: tools so to create this i was doing that
Caption: in the dev tools and then copying that
Caption: value across and adjusting as i need it
Caption: now for the white border we can't use
Caption: grid gap because everything's
Caption: overlapping so the box the container has
Caption: a white background and then the same
Caption: clip path is added to the image but jen
Caption: just shrunk down a little bit
Caption: and because we're doing that we need to
Caption: slightly tweak the transform origin
Caption: because we're dealing with some pretty
Caption: funny shapes here there's a lot of
Caption: little adjustments you'll need to do
Caption: when you start making shapes like this
Caption: but
Caption: that's one of the downsides of the
Caption: technique you're going to have to manage
Caption: the grid gap manually yourself
Caption: but there we go we've recreated the
Caption: shapes from that comic which when you
Caption: initially look at it you would have
Caption: thought there's no way we can do that
Caption: sort of layout on the web
Caption: and if you haven't seen it yet each of
Caption: the links underneath it to the code pen
Caption: versions of each of these so you can
Caption: have a look at them and play but i have
Caption: a another link at the end which will
Caption: link to all of them
Caption: so clip path is no doubt a powerful tool
Caption: when combined with grid so we're going
Caption: to have another
Caption: example here which is detective comics
Caption: number 876
Caption: taking the grid layering and from our
Caption: earlier examples we can recreate this
Caption: same layout the drawing's a little more
Caption: intense
Caption: but it's the layout in the background
Caption: we're going to focus on batman could be
Caption: done by
Caption: just the layering that we looked at
Caption: before
Caption: the shapes can be recreated by adding
Caption: perspective and rotating the panel so
Caption: we've added our grid we're adding a
Caption: panel to the grid in similar ways that
Caption: we have before and then we transform we
Caption: use some perspective that gives us that
Caption: nice little angle and rotate it into
Caption: that and then the same with panel two
Caption: all the way down but you can see there's
Caption: a problem here
Caption: in that the blue background of each of
Caption: them is coming through we didn't want
Caption: that we wanted just the squares going
Caption: down the page and sort of forming one
Caption: shape
Caption: again we can use clip path here to cut
Caption: out the part clip path is sort of
Caption: showing the part that we do want visible
Caption: so you're kind of doing you're not
Caption: cutting out the stuff that you don't
Caption: you're making the part that you do want
Caption: visible but with each panel having a
Caption: clip path on it
Caption: it gives the impression of a border
Caption: going all the way down while giving us
Caption: that shape so it's again something quite
Caption: interesting and different for the web
Caption: so there it is next to mr batman
Caption: now clip path isn't limited to just
Caption: polygons there is a lot going on in
Caption: these images but we have flash on the
Caption: side and i particularly enjoy the cats
Caption: up the top here
Caption: it looks like two-face to keep with our
Caption: comic book thing so we've got our
Caption: polygons that we've seen
Caption: but
Caption: there are some other options ellipse
Caption: allows for oval shape again the first
Caption: two values are our radius and then the x
Caption: and y allows us to offset it a little
Caption: bit
Caption: and circle for a more uniform shape
Caption: similar to ellipse the first value is a
Caption: radius followed by the position and we
Caption: can have something else
Caption: so clip path affected the shape of the
Caption: container but we can also have the text
Caption: react to the shape of the container as
Caption: well using css shapes
Caption: this is a panel from saga and the part
Caption: that's
Caption: important here is how the moon has its
Caption: curve or the planet and then the text is
Caption: also curving along that now this has
Caption: existed in magazines for a long time
Caption: but it's been absent for from the web
Caption: but again we'll do a little bit of setup
Caption: here we have our panel position relative
Caption: because we're moving things about again
Caption: uh paragraph we shift it into place and
Caption: the important part here is our image
Caption: which we've moved to the side we could
Caption: have done this with grid as well uh the
Caption: width and the height but the shape
Caption: outside is what we're interested in the
Caption: circle
Caption: so firefox again has been helping us
Caption: developers out with the dev tools we can
Caption: apply a shape outside and just use some
Caption: values
Caption: but then we can select that icon and
Caption: start resizing in real time and
Caption: i am certainly a visual kind of a
Caption: learner and
Caption: i like to see things happening with code
Caption: maybe that's why i prefer the front end
Caption: but
Caption: we can see that and we can take those
Caption: values and we can move it back to our
Caption: css so it's really nice that the tools
Caption: are helping us with this creative coding
Caption: side of things
Caption: that didn't mean to skip but we'll move
Caption: on
Caption: the shapes can also be more complex than
Caption: just circles so
Caption: there is definitely going to be a moment
Caption: in your career where a designer comes to
Caption: you and says we've got a cat
Caption: and we need the text to wrap around it
Caption: you guys saw these ones
Caption: and so we can use the polygon shape that
Caption: we've had before and we can draw around
Caption: our cat and we can do that
Caption: now
Caption: we can also
Caption: with something that clip path didn't
Caption: allow us but shape outside does is use
Caption: an alpha mass so if we have our cat
Caption: and then we have an alpha mass that
Caption: represents the shape of our cat very
Caption: similar to a background image we can say
Caption: shape outside url cat mask there's some
Caption: cause funniness in here
Caption: but that's boring this is kind of what
Caption: we're gonna look at here and you can
Caption: look at the course problems later it
Caption: needs to be on the same domain
Caption: essentially
Caption: so what we've created is a great example
Caption: of the modern web but it is based on a
Caption: western modern web it's western comics
Caption: styles and structures
Caption: that's reading left to right top to
Caption: bottom
Caption: the structure and reading style isn't
Caption: the only comic structure that exists
Caption: though for instance japan has a very
Caption: healthy industry with its manga
Caption: i've been a particular fan of naruto for
Caption: a while so it's fun again that i get to
Caption: just keep
Caption: putting all of my uh hobbies into this
Caption: talk
Caption: but this is the same page from the manga
Caption: in japanese and in english now even with
Caption: the english one we can see that the
Caption: start is on the other side to what we're
Caption: used to and it finishes on the other
Caption: side of there
Caption: but the english version even though it's
Caption: translated they kept the layout the same
Caption: we could position the cells in our grid
Caption: in this way
Caption: quite
Caption: straightforward but we'll remember from
Caption: before
Caption: the source order matters so if we were
Caption: to have alt text and everything on here
Caption: if we were to put it in that order then
Caption: the screen reader is going to read it
Caption: somewhat backwards more from the top
Caption: down to the other side
Caption: oops
Caption: so when placed into the grid with a left
Caption: to right direction we can do it like so
Caption: we'll have our first panel second third
Caption: through to the sixth so similar to at
Caption: least in my experience a reading style
Caption: that i'm used to
Caption: grid has us really
Caption: well covered for internationalization
Caption: when direction right to left
Caption: is applied this can be in multiple
Caption: places in the page but i've done it
Caption: directly here on the main
Caption: grid just flips it
Caption: to what right to left is so panel one is
Caption: now over to the side two three four five
Caption: so we've covered the accessibility by
Caption: putting it in the correct order we've
Caption: added our grid but then we've enabled
Caption: other styles with a simple property
Caption: so of interest in this comic you'll
Caption: notice the difference in grid gaps
Caption: in the example you can do that as well
Caption: with uh grid gap it doesn't always have
Caption: to be consistent in here we're affecting
Caption: the horizontal and the vertical gap
Caption: what's also worth noting in the manga is
Caption: that the text runs vertically but in
Caption: english it's left to right
Caption: now i didn't want to attempt to write
Caption: japanese so i did it with english and
Caption: you do get a bit of a weird thing where
Caption: the text runs that way but with writing
Caption: mode vertical right to left
Caption: it will
Caption: go in the direction that someone like
Caption: that would be expecting
Caption: with a logographic typeset such as what
Caption: japanese has that will work out
Caption: correctly
Caption: not actually sure why it does that with
Caption: english but i'm sure there's a really
Caption: valid explanation
Caption: so that brings us to the end of our
Caption: journey through the ages of comic and
Caption: how they can be brought to the web
Caption: i mentioned at the start that although
Caption: the examples are for comics to think
Caption: about how you can apply these to the
Caption: projects that you're working on and i
Caption: hope the various effects that i've
Caption: demonstrated have sparked some ideas of
Caption: something different that you can do with
Caption: layout
Caption: and taking it to the everyday products
Caption: of the web
Caption: we've been in these layout boxes for
Caption: quite some time so imagine when you
Caption: apply these layouts to your projects
Caption: sort of great things will start to
Caption: happen
Caption: and that's why i believe we're now in
Caption: the modern age of the layout on the web
Caption: css grid gives us great new powers and
Caption: flexibility with our layout we saw how
Caption: we could stagger content layer our
Caption: panels to create depth and interest the
Caption: coming css grid level 2
Caption: spec will give us the ability with
Caption: subgrid to align better across multiple
Caption: panels
Caption: and getting a little more creative and
Caption: breaking out of the layout box the css
Caption: shapes clip path and shape outside
Caption: making our projects as accessible to as
Caption: wide an audience as possible with grid's
Caption: great support for internationalization
Caption: i mentioned earlier that the code pens
Caption: were all available this is the url where
Caption: you can find them and i also have it
Caption: linked on my twitter if you want to have
Caption: them play around with those
Caption: in a talk setting it can be hard to get
Caption: through everything
Caption: did you get the photo do you want me to
Caption: go back
Caption: it can be hard to get through everything
Caption: in a talk setting so i've written blog
Caption: posts that go through each one of those
Caption: areas and it goes into a lot more detail
Caption: than what is possible in a talk so that
Caption: can be useful for you as
Caption: well
Caption: so stan lee had a famous catchphrase he
Caption: used to sign off letters and
Caption: correspondence that he had with fans
Caption: which was excelsior and as a little bit
Caption: of a hat tip i thought it would be nice
Caption: to include that in my talk as a closing
Caption: he's had a great effect on many comic in
Caption: uh sorry in many creative industries and
Caption: but after looking up its meaning i sort
Caption: of thought it was a really fantastic way
Caption: to finish a talk
Caption: excelsior stands for ever upwards so i
Caption: think take what you learned from this
Caption: talk and all the other great talks today
Caption: and see how you can apply that to what
Caption: you're working with
Caption: thanks very much
Caption: thank you so much for that amazing talk
Caption: anton we've got about five minutes for
Caption: questions
Caption: hey uh thanks for the presentation this
Caption: was really good um
Caption: it's mercy story in mcu
Caption: what was that saying
Caption: it's merfisto it's going to be an mcu
Caption: no
Caption: i can't do any of their stuff on the web
Caption: so i have a question
Caption: what would you advise is the best
Caption: approach to take for somebody new to
Caption: using something like css grid
Caption: well i i mean what this is the way that
Caption: i learned the css grid it was the talk
Caption: is a little bit older now um
Caption: but linking it with something that you
Caption: enjoy i think is a good way to learn it
Caption: i
Caption: kind of knew some of these comics and
Caption: and looked at the layouts and i was
Caption: trying to use grid in products
Caption: that designers would send me but it was
Caption: always trying to visualize something
Caption: that i didn't quite understand yet
Caption: because the
Caption: the layouts that they were doing didn't
Caption: have these grids and these structures to
Caption: it so taking a bit of a step back and
Caption: starting to work with grid with comics
Caption: in my case
Caption: uh
Caption: was nice because it could start off
Caption: quite simple and then build up to our
Caption: more advanced
Caption: examples with the
Caption: sort of breaking out the boxes and
Caption: starting to combine those techniques
Caption: together
Caption: so yeah i would say link it with
Caption: something that you enjoy doing
Caption: i think that's good advice for
Caption: everything really
Caption: um if there's no other questions could
Caption: we please have another round of applause
Caption: for anton
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: and it is now lunchtime i'm sure
Caption: everyone's hanging out for food um if
Caption: you remember on your lanyard there
Caption: should be a number go to the table that
Caption: has your number on it if your lanyard
Caption: does not have a number head down to the
Caption: help desk
Caption: and we'll be having some q a panels here
Caption: in the riverside room and also in the
Caption: theater
Caption: in an hour so that'll be 2 35
Caption: thanks everyone we'll see you later
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puppies
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the barrack completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: there it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also got a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better um i think that's really
Caption: important and i think it's going to be a
Caption: driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's uh if you want to grow up in
Caption: your career you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience
Caption: and boost your personality everything in
Caption: a compact pack that's what planet is for
Caption: me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their i.t needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: oh
Caption: which
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are going to love it
Caption: i got a real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for one
Caption: hundred 000 teammates ambition is how a
Caption: children's hospital built an app to
Caption: reduce stress for families ambition is
Caption: how a law firm rallied against a malware
Caption: attack to reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together
Caption: now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stopped
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of um sparks and enjoy and so yeah
Caption: so being better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow i also got a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to
Caption: want to learn and get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top 1 is the best of the best and for me
Caption: it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your
Caption: carrier you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here to boost your experience and boost
Caption: your personality everything in a compact
Caption: pack that's what planet is for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on uh
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made sure dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now auth zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hi
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your career
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here to boost your experience and boost
Caption: your personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: good
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: my dream poses true i've always wanted
Caption: to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their i.t needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: do
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero up what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hi
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: is nerd's nerding what we're doing is
Caption: we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our focus
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the barrack completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn it does not
Caption: reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience
Caption: and boost your personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: poses like dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: god
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: this is office nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret uh as you can tell by the
Caption: accent i am french very very prominent
Caption: accent
Caption: so the barrack completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn it does not
Caption: reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: a lot
Caption: like dream come true i've always wanted
Caption: to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services mo q digital
Caption: helps clients to fully understand their
Caption: it needs adopt the right solution and
Caption: provide ongoing support to maximize
Caption: their investment
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: hello
Caption: i'm not used to handheld mics i'm not
Caption: sure how far to do it
Caption: welcome to the 315 session
Caption: today we have sarah miguel
Caption: she will be
Caption: giving her talk failure 101 what life
Caption: lessons can teach us about better
Caption: software development
Caption: sarah has had a career that can only be
Caption: described as eclectic
Caption: but the prevailing theme has been a
Caption: passion for bringing people together and
Caption: supporting teams to use data to drive
Caption: the best outcomes for customers
Caption: stakeholders and business
Caption: give a warm welcome to sarah
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you
Caption: um now who here has ever failed at
Caption: something before
Caption: yeah failed to meet a deadline
Caption: personally i failed to get out of bed
Caption: with my first alarm this morning so i
Caption: made it it's fine
Caption: and who here has been part of a software
Caption: project that's failed before
Caption: yeah maybe an incident
Caption: well i'm not surprised it's pretty much
Caption: everyone in this room because failure is
Caption: a big part of life and it's a massive
Caption: part of working in tech
Caption: and in building software
Caption: code fails to execute all the time bugs
Caption: pop up seemingly from nowhere
Caption: and sometimes even with an ide you fail
Caption: to find that one
Caption: missing semicolon
Caption: now we as individuals are usually pretty
Caption: good at finding the cause of these
Caption: little errors
Caption: but when it comes to a big project
Caption: often it's not until that post modern
Caption: retro or that post-incident review
Caption: that you sit back and go
Caption: yeah
Caption: that's why we failed
Caption: well luckily
Caption: i've been failing pretty much my whole
Caption: life i constantly fail
Caption: and
Caption: i've worked in probably more industries
Caption: than any one person should have this is
Caption: just a selection
Caption: and in the past few years i've worked in
Caption: incident and problem management so
Caption: fixing the problems
Caption: software development causing them
Caption: and as a scrum master trying to help
Caption: others not cause them
Caption: and
Caption: i'm also on twitter i often fail to
Caption: update this but you're welcome to follow
Caption: me anyway
Caption: now the benefit of me having worked in
Caption: so many industries is that i've seen
Caption: what failure looks like across all kinds
Caption: of projects
Caption: and i can tell you that it's the same
Caption: few things that cause a project of
Caption: whatever kind to fail
Caption: but one thing i can't fail to do today
Caption: is to mention the amazing sponsors
Caption: who make this possible um so if you
Caption: haven't already please make sure you go
Caption: get your treasure map stamped win some
Caption: pretty cool stuff
Caption: so today i'm going to use a couple of
Caption: examples from my personal life don't
Caption: worry they are embarrassing
Caption: to walk you through some of the mistakes
Caption: that we made and how they can snowball
Caption: into those big failures
Caption: so i'm gonna take you back a bit in my
Caption: life to my childhood
Caption: i'm about five years old
Caption: it's the start of term two and i'm at a
Caption: brand new school
Caption: i'm in the pre-primary class and i'm
Caption: standing at the starting line of the
Caption: very first event of the day at our
Caption: athletics carnival
Caption: and then the sports teacher comes over
Caption: to us and explains what this event's all
Caption: about
Caption: they tell us that what you need to do
Caption: is to try and run and reach the finish
Caption: line as fast as you possibly can
Caption: now
Caption: i've been around the block a bit we're
Caption: in the lead up to the sydney olympic
Caption: games i've seen a running race on tv
Caption: i know exactly what it is that i'm doing
Caption: here right and i look down the track and
Caption: i can see the finish lines in each of
Caption: the lanes each with that finishing
Caption: ribbon set across between the two posts
Caption: so i think to myself yeah
Caption: i've got this and you know what i'm
Caption: going to show everyone at my new school
Caption: that i am pretty cool
Caption: so at the finish line
Caption: ready
Caption: set
Caption: go
Caption: and we're off we're running i'm running
Caption: as fast as my little legs can carry me
Caption: and the finish line is very rapidly
Caption: coming up
Caption: i'm gonna get there first i'm gonna win
Caption: this so i'm running and i hit the finish
Caption: line
Caption: and i fall flat on my face
Caption: you see what i thought was a set of
Caption: finish lines turned out to be a set of
Caption: hurdles and
Caption: at five years old i hadn't encountered
Caption: this before and not only did i fall down
Caption: i caused a terrible domino effect
Caption: children's limbs flying everywhere as
Caption: the person next me fell down and
Caption: cascaded down the lanes
Caption: so where did i quite literally i might
Caption: add
Caption: fall down
Caption: well it started with assumptions
Caption: i assumed that because this looked
Caption: similar to something that i'd seen on tv
Caption: that it must be the same
Caption: and not only that the sports teacher
Caption: assumed that everyone at that stand
Caption: like that starting line had been there
Caption: the term before
Caption: and attended the class where we learned
Caption: exactly what hurdles were and how to
Caption: jump over them and not run through them
Caption: the second mistake here was my own fear
Caption: of embarrassment
Caption: i was the new kid at school so even
Caption: though i recognized this didn't look
Caption: exactly the same to what i'd seen on tv
Caption: i was too scared to ask that question
Caption: and thirdly there was some really poor
Caption: communication
Caption: when that sports teacher told us to run
Caption: and try and reach the finish line as
Caption: fast as possible
Caption: did that really communicate what you
Caption: needed to do in an event like hurdles
Caption: and look it boils down to the fact that
Caption: we didn't clearly communicate
Caption: or understand the requirements
Caption: and this isn't something that affects
Caption: just me
Caption: we see it every day
Caption: the 125 million mars probe that failed
Caption: because people assumed they were working
Caption: in the same units
Caption: or the junior developer who picks up a
Caption: card for an api to do something
Caption: and then they build it in java only to
Caption: find out that hey it was meant to be
Caption: built in c sharp
Caption: so how do we avoid this
Caption: firstly validate your assumptions check
Caption: with your team members with your product
Caption: donor or program manager and if possible
Caption: with your stakeholders and end users
Caption: ask the stupid questions don't be like
Caption: me and let your fear of embarrassment
Caption: get in the way of you asking a question
Caption: because i can pretty much guarantee
Caption: someone else in the team has the same
Caption: thoughts as you
Caption: and make sure that you have a shared
Caption: understanding of what's required spend
Caption: that bit of extra time in your inception
Caption: and then document that for the next
Caption: person
Caption: moving on a little bit a little bit
Caption: older a little bit wiser
Caption: and i'm in my final year of university
Caption: i'm working on my thesis which is
Caption: investigating potential causes of liver
Caption: disease
Caption: now for anybody who's done biochemistry
Caption: and seen diagrams like this before i
Caption: apologize for reinflicting that trauma
Caption: on you
Caption: for everybody else i'm going to try and
Caption: explain what it is that i was working on
Caption: without throwing too many terms like de
Caption: novo lipogenesis or esterified fatty
Caption: acids at you
Caption: so the liver is the body's central hub
Caption: for metabolism
Caption: each one of the arrows on this diagram
Caption: represents a pathway where something is
Caption: metabolized from one thing to another
Caption: for your context there's about 135 of
Caption: them i cannot fit them all on one
Caption: diagram
Caption: but my team was invested in particularly
Caption: two pathways
Caption: we're looking at how the body breaks
Caption: down fats and i was specifically
Caption: focusing on how the body metabolizes
Caption: iron and as a whole we're looking to see
Caption: what happens between these two pathways
Caption: when the liver gets stressed
Caption: so
Caption: for your understanding we selected our
Caption: gene targets those the items that are
Caption: sort of like boxed in blue
Caption: very carefully
Caption: we then determined what our experimental
Caption: controls would be
Caption: we worked very hard to ensure that we
Caption: were using the same consistent
Caption: methodology
Caption: and then we got to work
Caption: for three months we tested each of these
Caption: targets and then we came together as a
Caption: whole lab group
Caption: to share sort of our version of a proof
Caption: of concept
Caption: and yeah all of the genes all of these
Caption: things in blue
Caption: were giving us the results that were
Caption: expected the ones that we thought would
Caption: be active were and the ones that we
Caption: thought would be quiet
Caption: weren't really showing us any results
Caption: so we carried on with our work over the
Caption: next 12 months i tested these targets so
Caption: many times i
Caption: painstakingly followed our protocols
Caption: even down to like timing the seconds out
Caption: and i honestly crunch more data than i
Caption: think anybody knows what to do with
Caption: and then at the end of 12 months we came
Caption: together again each person who took a
Caption: different pathway in the liver and
Caption: shared our
Caption: results the only problem was they didn't
Caption: line up
Caption: now
Caption: as anybody who's been part of a software
Caption: project maybe you've dedicated a lot of
Caption: time of your life to that and had it
Caption: fall over or fail at the last minute
Caption: realizing that your work
Caption: for 12 months of your life
Caption: was wasted
Caption: that's a kick in the the guard that's a
Caption: slap in the face and that's exactly how
Caption: i was feeling when i found out that 12
Caption: months of my life were effectively
Caption: wasted
Caption: effectively
Caption: we failed
Caption: to test everything that we should have
Caption: so what didn't metabolize here in my
Caption: piece of work
Caption: well by only testing those gene targets
Caption: in blue and not everything that was
Caption: happening between them
Caption: we relied on the equivalent of unit
Caption: tests for an entire measure of quality
Caption: and we didn't test the entire process
Caption: end to end what happens between every
Caption: single one of those 135 pathways in the
Caption: liver so we didn't even have anything to
Caption: compare the results that we did generate
Caption: too
Caption: and we only tested and planned for the
Caption: happy path
Caption: so what happens
Caption: according to plan you know how the liver
Caption: is meant to metabolize things and given
Caption: that in this scenario we were
Caption: deliberately trying to stress it to
Caption: break down the metabolic processes
Caption: we really should have considered that
Caption: unhappy path
Caption: we just simply didn't test everything
Caption: that we needed to
Caption: and look that isn't something that's
Caption: just restricted to medical research
Caption: inadequate testing also contributed to
Caption: the failure of tsb banks software
Caption: migration in 2018
Caption: and that cost them 330 million pounds
Caption: and lost them 80 000 customers
Caption: so that's a pretty big mistake for not
Caption: testing something
Caption: so how do you get over this how do you
Caption: overcome a lack of testing
Caption: if at all possible consult the subject
Caption: meta experts before you start your
Caption: development work they can help you
Caption: ensure that you're testing everything
Caption: that you need to and that your
Caption: development practices are robust
Caption: please don't just rely on unit tests as
Caption: foundational as
Caption: important as they are if they're your
Caption: only measure of quality you could be
Caption: potentially missing something that will
Caption: cause you an error or a bug later
Caption: and consider the happy and the unhappy
Caption: parts in your testing because we all
Caption: know users i am a user and i know that i
Caption: mistake make mistakes all of the time
Caption: and i will find some way to break
Caption: something
Caption: now we come to the failure that frankly
Caption: i'm the most embarrassed about and the
Caption: most mortified so guys strap yourselves
Caption: in if you thought that was heavy
Caption: you see i was asked to bake a cake
Caption: it was for a friend's 21st birthday
Caption: party and they're a massive fan of the
Caption: movie madagascar
Caption: so we thought hey it's their 21st why
Caption: not embrace this and go full kids party
Caption: i'm talking balloons birthday patterns
Caption: everywhere pinata hanging from the
Caption: ceiling
Caption: and then we thought hey why don't we do
Caption: the birthday cake in the shape of their
Caption: favorite character from the movie king
Caption: julien
Caption: for those of you who haven't seen the
Caption: movie or have forgotten is this kooky
Caption: looking lemur with the crown
Caption: so why was i asked to bake the cake
Caption: well i have a confession for you guys
Caption: i'm a stress baker so when i get
Caption: stressed i bake
Caption: i baked recently in preparing for this
Caption: talk that's how stressed i was and it's
Caption: a hobby that i've kept up for the past
Caption: several years
Caption: i've baked everything from fully edible
Caption: terrariums so i'm talking candy glass
Caption: cake for the soil plastic sorry uh not
Caption: plastic
Caption: modelling chocolate i forget the fancy
Caption: french name for it but really fancy
Caption: things i've even made cartoon character
Caption: cakes before like finding dory or dory
Caption: from finding nemo if you didn't see the
Caption: sequel
Caption: so
Caption: making something like this amazing thing
Caption: shouldn't be too far out of my
Caption: wheelhouse right shouldn't be too far
Caption: from my level of
Caption: expertise so i did what anybody would do
Caption: in this situation and i went hunting on
Caption: the internet for inspiration this is
Caption: just one of the items that i sort of
Caption: like based
Caption: my cake on
Caption: i worked out everything that i would
Caption: need
Caption: and then i pre-ordered all of my
Caption: ingredients all the things i'd need for
Caption: decoration
Caption: fast forward a couple of weeks
Caption: the day before the party and i finish
Caption: work at lunchtime so i finish early
Caption: and then i go down to collect everything
Caption: that i'd pre-ordered
Caption: only problem was they didn't have half
Caption: the stuff i ordered
Caption: including the cake that i special
Caption: ordered
Caption: so
Caption: with very few options you know i'm a day
Caption: away from this party
Caption: i
Caption: had to come up with another solution
Caption: so i came up with a list of things that
Caption: i thought i could substitute in terms of
Caption: ingredients i grabbed everything that i
Caption: would need to bake cakes myself and i
Caption: headed home and got baking
Caption: i just pulled the cakes out of the oven
Caption: when i got a phone call from the other
Caption: person organizing the party asking me to
Caption: do them just a little favor and could i
Caption: run down and pick up
Caption: the guy's birthday present
Caption: now cakes have to cool after coming out
Caption: of the oven and i definitely can't start
Caption: carving them up or decorating them until
Caption: that's done
Caption: and i don't know if you guys know this
Caption: but birthday presents kind of a big deal
Caption: so
Caption: sure
Caption: but as anybody who works in perth cbd
Caption: knows that on a friday afternoon peak
Caption: hour traffic
Caption: is insane
Caption: so my quick errand quickly turned into a
Caption: three-hour long trip
Caption: and that meant that i just didn't have
Caption: the time that i needed that evening to
Caption: start assembling this cake
Caption: no problem i wake up even earlier the
Caption: next morning i get slicing my cake down
Caption: into all the shapes that i need i start
Caption: getting ready to assemble it
Caption: only to sort of get tapped on the
Caption: shoulder and told you know that we're
Caption: hosting this party right so we need to
Caption: start setting up at about mid afternoon
Caption: and you need to go get ready
Caption: so i'm looking at my half assembled cake
Caption: and i know that it's gonna take me at
Caption: least another eight hours to finish
Caption: assembling this especially given i'm
Caption: working with things that i am not
Caption: familiar with
Caption: so
Caption: something had to give
Caption: i decided i had to start from scratch i
Caption: rebaked some cakes
Caption: and here's what i was able to deliver
Caption: in a little bit over four hours i
Caption: completely rebaked cakes and i decorated
Caption: now look
Caption: it kind of it's the minimum viable
Caption: product right
Caption: it's a cake
Caption: it kind of resembles king julien on it
Caption: and look when i cut cut it open you know
Caption: the stuff did spill out like a pinata
Caption: cake
Caption: but it wasn't even close to what i
Caption: wanted to deliver it wasn't sort of what
Caption: we promised and it definitely wasn't
Caption: like this image which is what i was
Caption: aiming for
Caption: so i was still understandably
Caption: embarrassed and yet here i am sharing it
Caption: all with you guys
Caption: so how did i
Caption: somebody who's got years of experience
Caption: with baking
Caption: become a nail bit contender
Caption: well
Caption: the resources and tools that i planned
Caption: on having ingredients i was familiar
Caption: with pre-made cakes so i could focus on
Caption: decorating had to be substituted
Caption: the organizer didn't consider
Caption: conflicting priorities i mean yeah a
Caption: birthday present's important but so is
Caption: the birthday cake and realistically i
Caption: should have pushed back on me being the
Caption: person to pick it up surely someone else
Caption: could have
Caption: and i also failed to plan for changes in
Caption: my own capacity or for these unexpected
Caption: things to happen i could have allowed
Caption: myself even more time
Caption: at the end it just came down to pool
Caption: planning now this is a contributor to 71
Caption: of pro projects that fail so it's a big
Caption: one
Caption: and look
Caption: it's not just related to bank to baking
Caption: or anything else like that
Caption: poor planning caused a three-time cost
Caption: overrun
Caption: for the u.s national gas companies erp
Caption: update so they originally budgeted 330
Caption: million dollars and it cost them just
Caption: over a billion
Caption: to finish that project
Caption: that's a lot of money could have been
Caption: spent elsewhere
Caption: so how do we avoid becoming nailed at
Caption: contenders
Caption: if at all possible get your stakeholders
Caption: your party planners involved early and
Caption: make sure that you are on the same page
Caption: when it comes to what needs to be
Caption: delivered
Caption: when
Caption: plan ahead
Caption: for rework for unexpected tools and
Caption: changes in your team and your own
Caption: capacity
Caption: deliver your minimum viable product and
Caption: then continue to improve on it if at all
Caption: possible
Caption: so
Caption: how do we learn from my mistakes i mean
Caption: failure is inevitable sometimes it's a
Caption: big part of life it's part of developing
Caption: software
Caption: but you know those small mistakes that
Caption: i've made along the way that doesn't
Caption: have to snowball into a massive failure
Caption: so if you can ask yourself these couple
Caption: of questions the next time you're
Caption: working on a software project
Caption: are we all on the same page and is our
Caption: understanding documented
Caption: have we considered all parts in our
Caption: development and our testing
Caption: and have we planned for when things go
Caption: wrong
Caption: and is there a contingency plan in
Caption: place if you can answer yes to these
Caption: three questions
Caption: then you would have at least learned
Caption: from my mistakes
Caption: thank you
Caption: thank you sarah that was so good and it
Caption: was actually you said thank you when my
Caption: timer went clicked over to 20 minutes so
Caption: well done on perfect timing as well
Caption: uh so we don't have any time for
Caption: questions um but afternoon tea is being
Caption: served right now if you guys want to go
Caption: out the doors and uh the lock note will
Caption: be starting at five past four
Caption: uh so you've got
Caption: 25 minutes ish
Caption: if you want to head out
Caption: thanks everyone
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're sucking up
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem